okaya
hell for coming out tonight spending
your Saturday evening here
listening to a message from well I was
on the road last night and Spokan and
saw this with Dr wall and as Vivian
calls it the legend as you will find out
he's been doing this for a lot of years
several several messages like this
there's probably a reason why everybody
came here tonight not just to visit with
friends you came because you might
have a health issue with yourself or
friends noise up just a little bit a
health issue you came tonight because
you might have a health issue with
yourself friends or family and you heard
from a friend or on the radio this week
or from a young Jey associate that Dr W
was coming to town so you heard a little
bit about the protocol what he has to
offer and tonight he's going to present
some information to you and you're going
to be pretty amazed at some of the
things that he's discovered over the
years and the information he's trying to
get out to people and at this point Dr
Joel
Walling thank
[Applause]
you well thank you very much for
preparing for me I appreciate the snow
uh from California and um so this would
this would turn California into a mess
right so I appreciate you being here on
this uh Grand evening and I'm going to
just ask a couple of questions so I knew
know who I'm speaking to how many of you
heard me speak before okay great
appreciate you being here uh also how
many of you are Health Providers anybody
a health provider here okay what what do
you do I'm an rn rn rn good I love
nurses they keep doctors from killing
people okay give her a hand
[Applause]
okay okay anybody else over here I saw a
hand over here back there there was okay
sir what do you do Chiropractic okay
Chiropractic we love you guys and gals
okay anybody over here okay yes sir
Acure I'm sorry say again do of
acupuncture acupuncture it's okay super
uh 10,000 year old profession really
good stuff uh anybody else you notice
there's almost never a medical doctor
show
up why that's because they know
everything just ask them okay what we're
going to do tonight is have a little fun
at the same time learn some very serious
things the thing we're going to do
tonight is is make a um report card for
the medical system the goal here is to
keep the A's if there are any and throw
out the fs that make sense because they
haven't done it themselves they've
really botched things up very badly and
people say well who are you why why can
you be a judge here or do something well
the thing that makes my view different
is I have a degree in agriculture in the
animal industry we don't have health
insurance for animals like we do people
and if we were to use a human healthc
care type of system for livestock for
instance be a sticker shock for you a
hamburger would cost you $500 a pound a
dozen eggs be $250 just to pay for the
healthc care so we learned a long time
ago in the animal industry we keep the
price of animals and animal products
down to where the average person could
afford to eat them every day simply by
eliminating diseases we've been able to
eliminate 900 different diseases triple
lifespans just simply with vitamins
minerals no stem cells no genetically
engineered proteins Wonder drugs and
organ transplants as a kid it always
seemed odd to me that we did that for
animals and not for
people and again to make long story
short I got into a school halfway
through a school I decided I was going
to start applying for veterinary school
so when the time came am I a bad
boy uh we can't hear you we might need
two mics on you it's not on
that better we got you okay thank you
let's give Vivian a hand
okay okay thank
you um this should be okay um and so
halfway through AG school I decided I
was going to start practicing to apply
for veterinary school so when the real
time came when I graduated a school I I
know what I was doing well surprise
surprise the first time I applied for
for veter school halfway through a
school got accepted and so by the time I
finished a school two years later I was
a graduate student but I also had two
years left in ven school so I like
pathology so I started taking a lot of
pathology courses graduate courses and
comparative pathology doing autopsies on
humans and animals and the oh the first
winner as a graduate student all the
professors took off and left the
graduates in in charge of the various
service areas and my service area was
pathology and again lo and behold I it
case came to me in which it was the
first mass die off from pollution in the
United States and I got to write it up
and it became a very famous case uh had
did all the chemistry it was just
perfect it was written up in medical
journals and Veterinary journals and
international uh chemical journals and
that became the driving force of my life
that one study that just was sort of an
accidental thing well graduated um vener
school went to Africa for a couple years
because I had worked with Marlon Perkins
as a kid on the summer times remember
the old Mutual Omaha Wild Kingdom show I
started working for him when I was uh 14
years old this my one of my first jobs
at the St Louis with Marlon
Perkins I was 14 years old and they had
11 show elephants they started having
elephant shows in the 1904 World's Fair
and line of Tiger shows and chimpanzee
shows You' ever been to the St louiso
during the summer you know that and um
the elephants had learned something now
they teach up and the elephants would um
uh hold their bow booms all day they
just wouldn't poop on you know in the
barn so when they get on the stage they
make the first run around in circles and
this show went on four times a day
Monday through Friday June July and
August on Saturday and Sundays five
times a day and when they get on the
stage they you know the circus music
they go on the stage a few times they
start twirling around then they'd hook
up again trunk tail trunk tail kind of
thing and every other elephant so you
know they plotted this every other
elephant would poop on the stage the one
them would pick up these bowling ball
size manure balls and throw them out in
the
audience just and they would stand there
and giggle and watch everybody fleeing
right and so my job was to prevent that
by manually removing these bowling ball
siiz manure balls from the rectums four
times a day Monday through Friday and
five times a day on Saturday and Sunday
so that's my introduction to show
business right right
there well five years later when I
was 19 years old and these elephants are
now 15 years old you had to get deeper
into your
work
yeeha okay
so when I graduated veter school I was
already kind of two-thirds of the way
through my post-doctoral fellowship in
in comparative pathology Perkins had a
job for me and how many saw that there's
the Western black rhino is now extinct
in Western can western Africa did you
see that yeah well back back in um 1964
when I graduated vener school uh Perkins
sent me to Africa for two years to work
with a white rhino in in central and
southern Africa there was 250 left and
he set me up in this conservation thing
where I was supposed to catch them and I
caught 200 of the 250 sent them back so
if you see a white rhino and an elephant
uh and and elephants in the zoo uh you
either see them as offspring of the ones
that I caught or the ones that I caught
okay well two-thirds of the way through
this project I caught 200 out of the 250
um Perkins had gotten a grant from the
National Institutes of Health to study
pollution in the zoo animals and the
pollution in zoo animals was a great
idea how many remember the old Welsh
coal miners taking the canaries down in
the mine remember that and the canaries
would be more sensitive to the um oh
carbon monoxide and methane than the
humans and they would fall off the perch
and die long before the men were going
to were going to die so that they could
get out they see the canary drop off it
was time to run well Perkins had this
this great idea well here's a zoo in a
big city that had 400 500 600 species of
animals in there and they would die from
natural causes and usually if they're in
good shape they'd make mounted specimens
for museums and things but if they
weren't in good shape they would just
incinerate them you know cremate them
and he said well we should be able to
get some information to see if pollution
had anything to do with their causes of
death well since I was a comparative
pathologist and as out of courtesy
having worked with Perkins I used to
give him copies of all my scientific
articles that I'd written and he
remembered that I had done all this with
the first case of pollution Mass die off
in in the United States well he said we
can take 10 years to train somebody well
here's a guy wall he's got a degree in
agriculture he's a veterinarian he's a
pathologist and this this project was a
compilation of three departments the
Shaw's botanical gardens in St Louis
County the St Louis Zoological Park and
the biology Department of Washington
University so my training kind of fit
all those things so he called me back
back to work on that project it was a
10-year project I had done over 20,000
autopsies some
17,500 on over 454 species of animals
not all from the St Louis Zoo um zoos
all over North America including Mexico
and Canada all the United States little
bitty ones they would freeze and they'd
ship them overnight mail to me and the
big ones i' have to get on a plane with
a chainsaw and an ax and you know go to
the zoo where they died and and um do
the autopsy on them and then there were
3,000 people who had died and closed
proximity to these zoos they were also
autopsied and checked for pollution
problems well the book that came out of
that's a 1200 page book it's in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure and the whole purpose of that
book is to be a reference for things
that are going on now
comparing comparing the uh causes of
death from pollution nutritional
deficiencies 50 years ago compared to
now and so that book is used as a
reference for that purpose well because
of the publicity that was associated
with that project I was invited to speak
to Medical groups nursing groups
Pharmacy groups Dental groups to um give
them lectures on nutrition as part of
their continuing education so they could
keep their licenses well I was an
abysmal failure I was an abysmal failure
getting doctors interested in nutrition
you know they put their arm around me
and say w like that's all kind of
interesting but it doesn't pay for cat
scams okay and so I went back to school
and became a naturopathic phys I
graduated from ncnm in Portland Argan
practiced for 12 years my patients
affectionately said that I treated them
like dogs but they got
better and the reason was of course in
in the waiting room I had my Veterinary
degree which is so big it was like three
times as big as my naturopathic degree
and so they'd see that veteran degree
first and their eyes get very big and
they say am I in the right place and so
yes so what you're going to get is 33
years of information using Veterinary
nutritional phal on human patients
that's what you're going to get from me
and then together we're going to give
report cards to the medical system okay
so we're going to kind of do two things
at once I'm going to
use overheads to kind of share stuff
with you because if I were just to speak
to you without showing you these things
you would think I was sniffing glue
because some of the stuff is so
outrageous if I didn't show you the
source you'd say yeah right wall that's
impossible so here we go hold your
questions the end please and here we go
this came out cover article Time
Magazine uh December 2008
the sorry state of American Health
despite advances in medicine Americans
are less healthy than we used to be and
the Next Generation our kids may be
worse
off now there's two pieces here you have
to know number one we spend more money
for Health Care each year than all the
other nations of the world put together
each year Americans spend more money for
healthc care than all the other nations
of the world put together and yet our
health is getting worse what they're
saying here is our kids are not going to
live as long as us because they were
born into a bad system where many of us
are old enough we were Barn into a good
system and halfway through somewhere
along the line it got bad well our kids
are being Barn into a bad system between
pollution and food that's not good and
so on and so they're saying experts are
now saying that our kids are not going
to live as long as us and many of you in
this room will be standing at grave site
burying your children and your
grandchildren if we don't change if you
just keep doing what you're doing it's
not going to be good my favorite Nobel
Prize winner Albert Einstein said many
Global things that are unimpeachable
but my favorite is insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and expecting a
different result so we must change we
must change the medical system has
failed us terribly and so we have to
kind of take over here
okay here we
go now one of the most important parts
of a human's life and in any vertebrates
life for that matter you know whether
it's a hummingbird or a snake or an
elephant giraffe or a human doesn't
matter is the first third of the
pregnancy this is where the you go from
a sperm and an egg to a finished product
after the first third of that pregnancy
the rest of is just growth time the
individual forms in the first third of
the pregnancy now we've eliminated every
birth defect that you can name and three
times that many you can't name in
animals with preconception nutrition and
repeat that because you heard me but you
didn't hear me we've eliminated every
birth def that you can name and three
times that many that you can't
name in the animals in the animal
industry by simply giving the Fe
female's preconception nutrition perfect
nutrition before she gets pregnant in
humans we let everybody run around
eating Pop-Tarts and agos and Mountain
Dew and whatever it is they're eating
and then they miss two periods when they
get old enough to have their own family
oh you know I might be pregnant well the
embryo is already damaged at that
point we do a much better job for pigs
and rats and hamsters than we do for
ourselves and so there not should be
there should not be there should not not
be a single human baby certainly in
America born with a birth effect it's
totally preventable if we get every
embryo before they they're conceived
through the pregnancy that they're
developed in from the time they're born
until they're old enough to have their
own families we have to start somewhere
so we're going to start in the middle
here for some people now cuz we're not
embryos anymore you have to stop
that you do that again I'll squirt you
with a squirt
gun okay she's sitting here cracking her
Knuckles she
you have arthritis
already she needs
you you're not going to get me if you
keep cracking your
knuckles
okay this is our goal here is it the
three month Mark is to have a perfect
embryo and the OBGYNs have failed us
terribly they have failed us personally
what I'd like to see is a system of laws
because there are no laws covering this
either ethical laws or
legislative laws if it were up to me
every time that a pregnancy winds up
with a child that's born with a defect
of some kind the obgy should go to jail
for 25 years to
life now by the time by the time that
the thousand's doctor Goes to
Jail every doctor run around saying I've
discovered that we can prevent birth
Effects by giving everybody vitamins and
minerals CU they wouldn't want to be the
thousands and first to go to jail but
that's not going to happen because
they're too powerful so we're wasting
time and money and energy hoping and
praying that they'll figure it out or
that by our petitions they will change
their ways so we just have to do it so
it's now your responsibility because
you're not ignorant anymore you're all
smart but you're ignorant because
everybody in this room did not know that
you can prevent all birth defs with
vitamins minerals before conception well
now you know and so you have a huge
responsibility do not depend on the
medical system particularly OBG YN have
failed us they do not get 30 minutes of
nutrition in 14 years of medical school
they don't even get a test on that they
don't even get a test on that 30 minutes
the most important thing in that
embryo's life is
nutrition okay so we have to take
control
here just to kind of put this in
perspective this came out a month ago
October 4th 2011 in ranking of newborn
deaths were number 41 it's the USA Shame
Shame on us Shame Shame Shame on the
OBGYNs because there's 40 other
countries who do a better job in having
live births and babies born without
birth the effects and first year
survivability shame on
us this we're spending more money for
healthc care than all the other nations
of the world put together and this is
what we get you wouldn't tolerate this
in any other industry this is your kids
and grandkids that are being affected
here and you're paying the price not
only in misery but also in
money because you're the ones that have
to pay for the obgy and's negligence and
mistakes now you say w you're kind of
rough on those doctors aren't you and my
response is I couldn't do it if they
didn't give me the material could I
now Down syndrome is a very simple
disease to prevent it's not a genetic
disease it's a simple nutritional
deficiency of the embryo in the first
couple of minutes of
life if the mother has perfect nutrition
prior to conception they'll never be
another Down Syndrome baby born Down
syndrome in humans is triom 21 where
there's three chromosomes instead of two
this just happens to be from a
chimpanzee where is triom 22 this is
totally
preventable totally want 100%
preventable it's not an accident it is a
nutritional deficiency the embryo just
moments after the egg is fertilized by
the
sperm if the mother's deficient you have
a high probability any these problems
now in
1977 being transferred around on this
big project from Perkins I went to
various zoos and so forth well 1977 I
was at the yeres primate Center in
Atlanta
Georgia and emry University and I
discovered the cause for prevention and
cure of cystic fibrosis this is
1977 34 years ago I discovered the cause
prevention and cure of cystic fibrosis
this is one of my research monkeys and
this is me when I was a young
man but I wanted to show you this this
was a news released by emry University
back in March of 78 several months after
discovery was made and confirmed you see
the name there Dr Joel wallik that's me
and they fired
me they fired because they knew that
cystic fibrosis was caused by a genetic
defect and they felt that I was sniffing
some glue or did something really crazy
to be able to falsely say that it was
caused by nutritional deficiency during
pregnancy so instead of saying well
that's kind of wild wall like you have
to prove it to us some more they just
fired
me because they didn't want to interrupt
the income stream to study
genetics are you getting a picture here
yeah now how many of you heard of
muscular distrophy
now we've known the cause prevention
cure of mustard distopy for 60 years
we've known the cause prevention cure of
musard disty for 60 years I'm going to
say one more time we've known the cause
prevention and cure of musular disy for
years now anybody here ever work with
cattle y okay um what do you you you
ever heard of white muscle disease okay
what causes white muscles is a
deficiency of what selenium a trace C
very good now are you a doctor sir no
are you a veterinarian no just a farmer
just a farmer a farmer now you know more
as just a farmer you know more about
mustard distopy than all the medical
doctors in the
world let's give him a hand I like
that remember we don't have health
insurance for animals do we and when you
have a calf with white muscle disease
you can give them some selenium and it
goes away if you give the female the cow
selum
before she has that calf you'll never
have another calf with white muscle
disease well white muscle disease in
calves is muscular distopy in humans
muscular Dy in humans is white muscle
disease and
Cals and we've been
curing white muscle disease in calves
and musard distopy in human beings for
over 30 years in my own practice but you
do one here and you you know then two
years later you do one there and the
doctors say well yeah who knows about
whether the diagnosis was correct we
found a group of people in Indiana
called the Amish in Three Counties
there's no selenium in these Three
Counties as soil surveys by Purdue
University's Department of Agriculture
not me Purdue
University
and in these Three Counties almost half
the kids are born with musard
distopy now what the medical system says
I I I'm telling you this is what the
medical system says they write write it
up in their scientific journals the
reason why there's so much mustard
distopy in these Amish communities in
these Three Counties is because they
just in
breed the fathers have sex with the
girls and the mothers have sex with the
boys and the brothers have sex with
their sisters and they just have no
morals they're all inner breeding and
that's why they have so many kids bned
with mustard
disy now I went and lived with them for
weeks that's not true they're very very
very very religious people Dutch Farm
church I mean they are religious believe
me and is because there's no selenium in
the soil there now it's kind of
interesting that they don't have white
muscle disease in their calves and their
goats and their sheep and their horses
and pigs and chickens you know why
because they supplement with selenium
for their
animals but they don't supplement for
selenium for themselves because the
doctors tell them oh it's genetic just
eat well you're going to get everything
you
need shame on those doctors they should
all be put in jail right on you're going
to see why in just a moment okay they
should all be put in jail for that kind
of
stuff you can see why they call Mustard
distopy white muscle disease in animals
this is the thigh muscle of a a teenage
boy with mustard distopy and so a farmer
out there not knowing what this is he'd
say oh this looks like white muscle
disease this is a normal thigh muscle
from a teenage boy okay and usually with
mustard disy the calves are much bigger
than the thighs because the thighs are
what waste away it's called duchan
muscular disy the interesting thing
about this is this part of the anatomy
in humans is the round steak and the
rump roast in in animals so when that
goes away you can't make money you're
losing money you feed that cow and you
have a calf like that you're you're done
that year you're not going to make any
money you're broke and so we learn very
quickly how to solve the problem by
giving selenium in the feed to the
animals and these places and they don't
get the disease anymore in human beings
doctors still falsely tell you
criminally tell you just eat well you
get everything you need it is absolutely
not true okay and here this this kid is
fixable with s
supplementation
now remember every birth effect you can
name let's just look at something simple
like a belly button Heria how many you
ever seen a belly button Heria in a baby
okay now this is caused by a zinc
deficiency in the
embryo in the last couple of days of the
first month of pregnancy you can see
here's kind of a Banny egg size belly
button hernie the Skin's over it and in
this early stages you can actually take
these kids lay them on their back and
take your finger four or five times a
day and rub that and irritate it and the
scar tissue will actually close over
probably won't need surgery Grandma used
to know that well here's another belly
button hernia but this one the mother
was deficient in zinc in the last couple
of days of the first month of pregnancy
and for the first 10 days of the second
month of pregnancy there's no skin over
this the stomach and some of the
intestines and the spleen are hanging
out and this is a life-threatening
situation certainly is a surgical case
this third
one the mother's deficient in zinc in
the uh last couple of days of first
month of pregnancy and for the entire
second month of pregnancy and so the
liver and the stomach and all the
intestines and spleen are hanging out
and this is a very dangerous operation
you see the the intestines are just
extended with gas and so forth so this
is a very precarious situation very
life-threatening and certainly if the
baby survives it's a it's a surgical
case all totally
preventable with you know 50 cents worth
of nutrients every day prior to
conception is that simple now you know
more than all
OBGYNs see how long it took you to learn
that now you've all seen kids with cleft
pallet cleft
lip these are caused by deficiencies of
nutrients in the earliest stages of
pregnancy I'm sure you can find a good
Christian surgeon to donate his time
here to close these kids' lips up and
and their pallets they're not going to
be beautiful because they're not going
to get 14 um plastic surgeries right but
they will be able to suck on a straw and
speak intelligibly all right now you can
go to one of these save the children
programs and get the 250 bucks each for
these kids to pay for the anesthesia the
Disposable instruments and the suture
material and so forth but all of this is
preventable with preconception nutrition
now how many you ever heard of autism
add or
ADHD now when I was a kid 72 years ago
there was no such thing that's because
we're all weaned off of Mama's breast
milk onto the cultural diets of where we
came from all four of my grandparents
came from the Ukraine Eastern Europe
along the Russian border and they were
beet farmers and cattle Farmers so I was
weaned off my mother's breath milk onto
eggs and beets and sweet potatoes and
cheese and milk with a little bit of
coffee in it and everything turned out
okay I think
okay but today let's say 30 years ago 30
years ago uh was one out of 150,000
American kids had autism and ADD and
ADHD today is one out of
115 and they're saying by 2025 it's
going to be one out of
50 now here's the scary part about this
if it's one out of 50 just about every
one of you eled officials regardless of
party is going to be
autistic if you think you have problems
now wait until all your elected
officials are autistic on top of
everything
else this has nothing to do with
vaccinations autism has nothing to do
with
vaccinations surely vaccinations can
cause catastrophic brain damage in a you
know handful of people but it doesn't
cause autism and ADD and ADHD you can't
you can't make that stretch autism and
AD D and ADHD are nutritional
deficiencies of the
brain brain requires more than just
sugar doctors say oh you know the brain
and fuel of sugar well that's true but
the brain needs all 90 essential
nutrients the brain needs all 90
essential nutrients and if it doesn't
have something your psychologist your
friendly psychist say oh you have a
chemical imbalance which is AKA
nutritional deficiency right so you take
the 90 essential nutrients you stay away
from sugar and it all goes
away but Prozac and Rin are not
nutrients
okay I've been dealing with these kids
since the 1970 by the
thousands all this stuff is totally
reversible with supplementation of all
the 90 essential nutrients and keeping
them away from sugar I also want you to
think about it all prenatal programs
with the exception of mine do not have
omega-3 essential fatty acid acids they
have capsules with folic acids which is
one of the lawsuits I've lodged against
the FDA to be able to say that
supplementation during pregnancy of
folic acid can reduce the risk of spinal
neurot tubal defects right spinabifida
before I sued them in federal court and
ju thank
you you can only you can only say that
eating foods rich in folic acid to
prevent these neurot tube defects I had
to sue them to be able to say you can
supplement and guarantee you're going to
get enough folic a to prevent that had
to sue them to be able to say the truth
okay now as I said earlier we're number
one in obesity in the world so we
finally made number one in
something we're number one in obesity in
the world and 44% of our kids under the
age of 12 or
obese this has nothing to do with um
lack of exercise and too much screen
time it has nothing to do with um eating
too much has nothing to do with eating
too
much now that's why we're the number one
obese nation in the world because the
doctor's theory was people just eat too
much too much green time not enough
exercise well following their recipe we
became the number one obese nation in
the world so obviously their recipe
their theory was wrong insanity is doing
the same thing over and over and
expecting a different outcome or a
different result so this is where we
must change because their theory is a
triple F now this is what doctors think
causes
obesity they even had McDonald's take
the toy out of the Happy Meal how dumb
is that how many calories are in the
toy I mean these guys have 14 years of
medical school and they think there's
calories in the toy take the toy out
that'll fix it
right now here's the first clue I'm
going to give you under what causes
obesity this little girl 3 years old was
on Good Morning America she was written
up in every newspaper in America you
might have even have gotten it here in
Montana 3 years old she eat light bulb
she's eaten aluminum can she eats dirt
and she eats wood and all this kind of
stuff and the the doctors who are taken
care of her in terod Indiana are very
ignorant they said she has a rare
condition called Pica well every
pregnant woman has Pica how many of you
ladies have had babies raise your hand
man okay great congratulations now how
many of you ladies when you were
pregnant had
cravings yeah well this is called Pica
because the embryo is stealing minerals
from you faster than you're taking them
in and so you want pickles and ice cream
in the old days women go out in the moon
lit night and eat dirt and and eat car
starch and and even Grandma knew about
this right the dog would go out and eat
eat grass you say grandma why is that
dog eating grass and she say he's
missing something you've all heard that
when you're a kid
right and so they call this a rare
genetic
disease right okay she's just missing
some minerals is there anybody in here
who's ever worked with horses anybody
work with horses okay what do you call
it when a horse chews on the fence
cribbing cribbing okay it's called
cribbing how do you get rid of cribbing
and a horse other than shooting
them you feed them minerals you give
them minerals within three to five days
they stop chewing on the fence for those
of you who have never seen cribbing this
is what it looks like
you can see where the horses here this
is a a little Amish farm in ship Shiana
Indiana you can see where the horses
were chewing on that rail in this uh um
pen inside the barn in this stall but
why did those horses really Go Gang
Busters there well that's where the
farmer I asked him if that was any place
special he yeah I stand there and I
count my horses and look at them for a
while to make sure they're okay before I
hitch them up on the buggy and that's
where I hold my hands well his sweaty
hands after doing all that work the salt
from his sweaty hands gets in that wood
and that's where the say dig in okay
now the reason why we give snacks to
people who come to visit our house is
over a hundred years ago it was
recognized very quickly that the the
guest kids would chew on your best
furniture so instead of letting them
chew on the legs of your best furniture
you give them a
cookie now how many you heard that the
government now is going to start taking
away your kids and your grandkids kids
if they're 25 to 50 lbs overweight okay
it's coming it's already started the
Journal of the American Medical
Association New England Journal of
Medicine Harvard Medical School and many
other medical schools are now
recommending to the government that
parents do such a bad job they want the
government to take your babies away from
you if you're overweight by 25 pounds or
more I've been a consultant on certain
cases with L as this one this young kid
here in Travelers Rest um South Carolina
his mother took him in uh to see the
pediatrician when he was 5 years old cuz
he's 150 lbs overweight the pediatrician
gave her a Frisbee with his name
telephone number and office address on
it said take him out in the park and run
him around throw the frisbee around make
him exercise she did two years later he
goes back in he's 250 lbs overweight and
so on and here he is 14 years old he's
430 lbs
overweight well this time the
pediatrician got scared called The
Social Services they arrest her and take
the kid away from her he's a w of the
state and they do stomach bypass and all
that kind of stuff now who should have
been arrested the pediatrician should
have been arrested because she did the
right thing she went to the doctor who's
supposed to know what to do for kids
with problems and he says exercise the
kid with his advertising
frisbee the pediatrician should have
gone to jail here and not the mother cuz
she s she sought help she sought
professional
help so beware they're coming after your
kids if they're a little
overweight we're going to have have to
have some battles
here now how many you heard of diabetes
anybody here ever hear of Diabetes Type
2 diabetes Well type 2 diabetes used to
be called adult onset type 2 diabetes
you can't call it that anymore it was
originally called adult onset type 2
diabetes because only people over age 50
got it well today 50% of the people with
type 2 diabetes are below 25 some of
them are born with type 2 diabetes now
this is a simple mineral deficiency
disease it's not genetic we've known how
to prevent and cure this disease for 60
years we've known how to prevent and
cure type 2 diabetes for over 60 years
let going say that one more time it's
not a genetic disease we've known how to
prevent and cure type 2 diabetes for
over 60 years it's a simple mineral
deficiency disease we'll talk about that
more in a minute but basically what you
do is before conception during pregnancy
from the moment the baby's born we all
need to get the 90 essential nutrients
appropriate for body weight
appropriate for body weight and as the
baby grows the amounts have to go up
because it's based on body weight right
if you do that we can we can make
Missoula Montana the first type 2
diabetes free town in two
weeks it takes two
weeks it's that
simple we can make no you got to hold it
until the end here I told you no
questions until the
end I have something for memory too
this is so simple it's scary this is so
simple is scary now to do this is going
to cost about three bucks a day per
person that's half or a third the cost
of an espresso latte mocha Poca DOA Loca
shoka now why won't doctors do this well
if you look on the other end of the
scale if you follow the doctor's method
of managing diabetes instead of getting
rid of it use a DI itic patient over 25
years are worth $4 million to the
medical
community there are no laws requiring
them to cure you either ethical laws are
legal legislative laws they require them
to cure you and there's a cure available
and so they don't because they make more
money in treating you and managing the
disease as opposed to getting rid of it
so now you know more I'm going to give
them the benefit of Doubt and assume
they're not criminals and just say
they're ignorant and don't know cuz they
only had 30 minutes of nutrition and 14
years of medical school but I can't
imagine they don't know because they
read the same journals I
do okay and so we're going to have to
take over here this is an F minus minus
minus minus if there's anything lower
than an F10 minus that's what they got
here on Diabetes there should not be a
single American and anybody in the
industrialized world with diabetes we
can get rid of it in two weeks it's that
quick same Principle as when you have
iron deficiency anemia you just give
iron it goes away you don't give a bone
marrow
transplant but that's what doctors would
like to do if you'd let
them and people always say well wallik
aren't you kind of rough on
doctors well I couldn't do that if they
didn't give me the material could
I in a heart of hearts we'd like to
believe that doctors are altruistic and
they do these things because they
believe it's good for us and they want
to help us and so on well in 1997 a
study by the Health Insurance
Association of America found found that
75% of insurance fraud which is a
federal crime is committed by providers
which is a code word for doctors this
was an anonymous survey so 58% of the
doctors responding to the survey felt
comfortable enough to admit that they
lie to get insurers to pay for
procedures they don't even
do a US Senate
committee back in October a year you
know a month ago October 2011 a senate
committee US Senate committee accuses
companies of gaming Medicare they're
talking about Home Health Services
they're talking about hospitals and
emergency rooms they're talking about
clinics where there's multiple doctors
in a clinic and basically what happens
is this if you go in there for a strain
and your ankle all puffed up and black
and blue because you got some blood in
there and everything it's painful
they'll take an x-ray and they say you
know we need to have an expert look at
this because we're just not quite sure
so we're going to check you into the
hospital tonight instead of sending you
home with an ice pack on your ankle and
having you see your doctor tomorrow
we're going to put you in the hospital
oh my gosh we need to put in a CAT scan
because we have to see if there's micr
fractures in there and they take
something that should have been a $200
bill to
$40,000 because you have insurance you
have Medicaid you have Medicare and
these doctors they've learned in the
senate committee will build eight
different agencies to pay them for doing
the one service they bill everybody they
can and get paid by eight different
services for doing one thing on you
you now that's fraud now you do that you
go to jail but they get a
walk then that make you feel warm and
fuzzy you're supporting the medical
community it's bad enough that even the
US senators can figure it
out that was a joke okay took me a
minute to I know it took a
while okay let's look at this a
different way let's look at outcomes
here to see you know with all the
nastiness that goes out in the medical
system maybe there's some good here well
let's see how long we live if everybody
in America dies at age three months
there's not going to be a next
generation is there but if everybody
lives be 150 that would be an A+
wouldn't it so let's have a look in 1990
the Center for Disease Control out of
Atlanta Georgia a federal agency that
tracks these kind of things looked at
the top 32 industrialized nations you
remember I said industrialized nations
not the top 32 Nations but the top 32
industrialized nations Japan came in
number one in longevity at
79.1 the French came in 11th at 75.9 we
came in 17th at 75 this is an F because
we spend more money for healthcare than
all the other nations of the world
combined annually we come in
17th and you wouldn't tolerate that in
any other industry would you let's have
a look 10 years later they redid it 10
years later they redid
it so in 2000 the same agency only this
time the
World Health Organization jumped in so
as the Center for Disease Control again
and and the um World Health Organization
Japan remained number one but they
dropped from 79.1 down to
74.5 the French moved up from 11th to
third but they dropped from 75.9 down to
73.1 and this Movement by the French
from 11th to third is called by American
medical doctors the French paradox they
call it the French paradox because the
French consume more fat per person than
any other culture on Earth ladies can
you imagine a friend Chef cooking in
canola oil and margarine no they cook
everything in butter and cream and lard
and eggs all the stuff we're not
supposed to eat right and yet they moved
up from 11th to third in longevity by
contrast fat is the Antichrist in
America next to the devil there's
nothing worse than anybody can figure
out than fat
okay I mean there's entrepreneurs that
have come up with a whole anti-fat thing
there's egg beers get egg white omelets
right and there's all these soy milk and
rice milk and rice dream and all this
kind of stuff and there's fa cheese you
know it's really wild stuff here and um
uh if you can't get your blood
cholesterol down below 200 oh I don't
want that I want a bottle that'll get
knocked
over I want a bottle you want to take
that with you please take it with
you I see disaster thank
you okay she's trying to be nice and
helpful but I appreciate that but when
you have an open glass like that you
know the odds are is going to get dumped
on my material I just know it okay all
right Murphy Never Dies Murphy Never
Dies very good Murphy's low whatever can
happen will happen all right and so did
you know that there's 12 companies that
make cholesterol luring drugs in America
12 pharmaceutical companies each one of
them makes a profit every month of two
billion to5
billion each one of these 12 companies
makes two 5 billion profit every month
in America because you are so paranoid
about
cholesterol well with all
that that same 10-year period we Dro
from 17th in longevity to
24th the system sucks the recipe sucks
that's an F minus minus minus minus
minus minus now here's what even makes
it worse listen up here this is what
makes it worse there's not a single
disease that is caused by elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides
people even stopped chewing their gum
when I said that they were so
shocked there's not a single disease
that you can show me that is caused by
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides you've wasted your time
money and energy worrying about your
cholesterol there's not a single disease
is caused by elevated blood show me one
there isn't
one if you read the words carefully they
say elevated blood cholesterol is a risk
factor for our heart disease doesn't
cause it it's a risk factor now let me
tell you if you have elevated blood
cholesterol whatever that means and I'll
give you a rationale here in a second
for that statement if you have elevated
blood cholesterol it means you either
have diabetes or you have low thyroid
you know hypothyroidism you can have
deficiency or ratio problems between
Omega-3s sixes and nines you can have
deficiencies of chromium vadium which
are two Trace minals that control uh
blood fats and blood sugar uh you can
have deficiencies of nasin remember the
Health Food Industries and and little um
health food store owners and herbalists
and naturopathic doctors and all these
people yelling about nasin forever for
low cholesterol right well the doctors
said medical oh that's all quackery and
charlatanism that can't be well now the
pharmaceutical industry came out with
Niaspan which is just a Time release
nias and vitamin B3 time release and
they charge your insurance company 150
bucks for one little bottle and you can
buy a bottle the same number of capsules
in nin for
$8 are you getting a picture here folks
okay
okay this came out in 2005 5 years later
they didn't wait 10 years to this time
it was 5 years
later and for the entire summer of 2005
June July and August this was on the
stands it was like five bucks it was a
half inch thick special issue on health
and in page 10 right hand column 2/3 of
the way down there was this part of a
paragraph America has built the world's
highest techch medical system I don't
think you can argue with that they got
robots now doing hip surgeries heart
surgeries prostate cancer surgeons
robots do this now why is that that's
because all the insurance companies got
together and they gave hundreds of
millions of dollars to engineering
schools like Mi and so forth to convert
automobile assembly robots into surgical
robots now why did they do that that's
because doctors were drunk so much letes
give Vivian a
hand thank you
thank you thank you um that's because
according to Harvard Medical School in
Lucian Lee the director of their
Department of Public
Health said and they did a survey a
blind survey 52% of medical doctors are
intoxicated on alcohol street drugs or
prescription drugs during their waking
day so you go to an emergency room 50%
of the time you're going to a doctor
who's gorked out on something okay and
so that's why and that's why they cut
off the wrong leg or they botch up a
surgery and so they had the robots do
this cuz the robots don't get
drunk so they don't have to give so many
settlements right that's why they did
that America's built the world's highest
Tech Medical system and for whatever
reason you can't argue with it there's a
comma here though and it says yet the
nation America now ranks 46 in life
expectancy behind Japan Singapore Canada
and virtually all Europe and Scandinavia
so in a 15-year period went from 17th in
longevity to 46th following the doctor's
recipe that's an fusus minus minus-
minus-- --us minus --us --us okay you
would not tolerate this in any other
industry why would anybody want to
listen to anything they had to say oh my
doctor is so wonderful I get free
samples every once in a
[Laughter]
while it gets
worse this was a full page article in
the USA Today February 2007
I had to chop it up a little bit to get
it on the 8 and 1 half by 11 sheet
because this was a full page newspaper
article you can tell by the title
there's something interesting that
happen here patient protect
thyself the data I'm going to share with
it comes from the journal the American
Medical Association the most prestigious
medical journal certainly in America
maybe the
world also the Center for Disease
Control again the federal agency out of
Atlanta Georgia what they said was this
each year in America each year in
America medical doctors kill injur and
infect 15 million of their patients in
the workplace Easter America medical
doctors kill injur and infect 15 million
of their patients their customers in
their workplace they don't even get an
OSHA
ticket 5.8 million in hospitals and 9.2
million in the private office and
Clinics and they get a
walk people keep going to them well it
happened in the world trade to the world
the world trade tower construction site
what would happen
if 10 plumbers a day were being killed
oh she would shut that thing down in one
day and it would be closed until they
figure out why it was happening I mean
people would be inin millions of dollars
right left and
Center this goes on year after year
after year after
year and we just keep paying the
increased prices every
year why do you do it it's an insane
process
you wouldn't do that in any other
[Music]
industry now one of our
Associates gave me this this is a story
from five years ago in an Orlando
Florida hospital this is one of the
injuries you know killed injured
infected this is one of the injuries
this gal here 28 years old goes in to
have her first baby well that's the
Russian version
she goes in to have her first
baby and when she wakes up from
anesthesia you know she's in trouble
right away she wakes up from
anesthesia and they had cut her arms off
at the elbows and they cut her legs off
at the groin she says oh my gosh my gosh
my baby your baby's perfect don't worry
about it and she said what' you do to me
and they said well you're going to have
to sue us to find out so she and her
husband sued the doctor in the hospital
they found out the doctor was drunk one
of those drunk doctors
and he read
her her chart wrong instead of
delivering her baby cut her arms and
legs off cuz he thought she was the one
that was in there for flesh eating
strip he went he went out and played
golf never had his license suspended
never lost one penny of income and this
is 18 months
later she'll never be able to hold her
baby's face in her hands she'll never be
able to wipe her own bottom eat with a
fork because the doctor was drunk on
duty now he's done that a second time
for a woman who went in for kidney
stones I don't know if he has a thing
against women I don't know what his
thing is but um this guy is a really a
bad negative there in Orlando Florida in
this Hospital well if I were her daddy
or her husband I'd make me a color
placard about 3 foot by 8ot of that I'd
make maybe a hundred of them and I put a
thing in here Dr so and so did this to
my daughter my wife
and I want you to boycott this hospital
until they fire him yeah I think but by
the time a week goes by I'll get a 100
people to be carrying that plaque around
with me right and so there has to be
consequences of these things if people
say oh isn't that a shame and then going
on about their business just like this
Penn State
thing report it nobody does anything I
mean if I walk into a shower and a coach
is having sex with a 10-year-old boy I'd
knock his lights out right
I'm not going to go tattle on him he's
going to wish I would
have okay so there has to be
consequences now these two ladies were
killed in a private office doctor's
office for having lipos suction instead
of using my weight loss plan they
decided getting their fat sucked out was
easier and the doctor kills them in his
office their doctor like many booming
cosmetic surgery field wasn't board
certified but there's no law to stop him
because doctors can do anything there's
no limit to to what a doctor can do they
can do
everything by legislation we've allowed
them to be able to do
anything okay and all he did just like
this previous girl that the arms and
legs are cut off the doctor gives the
survivors his card and says call my
insurance man and you guys settle he
goes on and does it to somebody else
there's no
consequences the system sucks and we
have to change it
this came out in 1998 again the study by
the Center for Disease Control of
Atlanta Georgia Federal agency and what
they said was that each year in America
medical doctors infect 2 million
customers 2 million patients in
hospitals each year they go in for
non-invasive things like ultrasounds CAT
scans stress test um x-rays that kind of
stuff and they infect 2 million of these
people of those 2 million that are
infected each year 90 ,000
die 990,000 die every year because the
doctor doesn't wash his
hands now I don't know how many of you
have heard of a farrowing barn this is
where pigs go to have their babies and
when you when pigs have their baby it's
called fing I don't know the derivation
of that but it's called farrowing and in
a fing Barn you could have a 100 fing
pens 100 SS 100 female pigs having their
babies there in these individual pens
they're little individual suets if you
don't work and live on that far arm you
go in that Barn you don't even go in the
pen with the pigs but you walk in front
of them you got to go and take a shower
with disinfectant soap in a special
clean room you got to tear open a bag
and put on disinfected coveralls and
boots gloves mask hat and in front of
each Pig Pen this barrowing pen is a 4in
deep 2ft X
2T 4in deep pan of disinfectant with a
brush you're supposed to step in that
take this brush and wash off your boots
before you go in front of the next pen
to prevent dragging infection from one
place to the next and then perhaps lose
these baby pigs and The Mamas from
infection by contrast I want you to
think about it these doctors both male
and females were the same white coat
room to room to room with the same shoes
from room to room to room same trousers
same skirt same panty hose room to room
to
room they were their surgical scrubs
down into the cafeteria where they sit
on a chair where some baby had poopy
diapers
eoli then they go back back and do
surgery or they go from room to room to
room whether it's a private practice or
the hospital they go from room to room
to room and you look at their jackets
they're not Snow White like they've just
been recently bleached you can look at
them they have blood and poop and pee
and puss and snot all over those things
they're dragging this from room to room
to room we treat our pigs better than we
do our
people that's why this happens so we got
to take control
here we actually have a a um skin
sanitizer called Pure works if you have
to have I hope you don't but if you have
to have somebody go to a hospital want
you to stand in the doorway with pure
Works say strip to your naked skin and
spray them all over with pure workor
where they can come in the room and
you'll save your loved one well I
couldn't do that he's a doctor you
better do it because he is a
doctor he gets
worse this came out last year almost
exactly last year November 2010 hospital
care failed for some patient that's kind
of vanilla this is a little scary a
results of Medicare study alarming
there's nothing more scary than alarming
okay now the study was done by the US
Department of Health and Human Services
office of Inspector General in this case
is essentially the auditor for Medicare
what they said was that each month in
America medical doctors kill 15,000
Medicare patients each month in
hospitals medical doctors kill 15,000
hospitals we still keep bringing our
loved ones to the hospital because our
minds and our hearts we hope and pray
that this is a place of safety and
health but statistics shows that it's
not can remember 60 Minutes you know
every Sunday
afternoon have you remember Andy
Rooney
oh now he retired a couple of months ago
at age of 92 a month later he was dead
people oh wasn't it terrible he passed
away well he didn't pass away he was
murdered
now I've read 15 of these articles
online newspapers all over the country
and every one of them says the same
thing Andy Rooney was
killed by
complications of a minor
procedure he was killed by complications
of a minor
procedure well why don't they tell you
what this minor procedure was but I
guarantee you here's
why you ever heard of colonoscopic exams
they put a garden hose up your rump and
they look around in
there I'm sure they said look Andy
you're 92 years old you better let us
check you out for colon cancer they put
this garden hose up his rump and the
surgeon's drunk starts poking around in
there punches it through his intestines
and he dies of partis an infection of
his belly
cavity if he just stayed away from him
he'd still be alive but they talked him
into this minor procedure that we do
every day and is safe right wound up
killing them
sure got quiet in here now if they can
kill an Andy Rooney with his high
profile see in these articles they
say oh you know he was such a kermon his
whole thing was to complain about things
right and we can see him up in heaven
complaining that he can't rest he can't
sleep because the harps for the that the
angels are playing is too
loud but that's not what Andy Rooney
would complain about Andy Rooney would
complain about being talked into a minor
procedure that wound up killing him
that's what he would complain
about okay this came out in August of
this year Newsweek magazine cover
article Newsweek magazine cover article
now this guy is obviously not
anesthetized here's five surgeons ready
to stick their scalpel into him because
if they stick the scalpel into him and
he dies they get paid the full amount of
the
procedure so they can't wait to stick
you because then if you die then they
get paid the full amount if you die you
know from anesthesia before they stuck
their knife in you they don't get paid
so they want to stick their knife in you
as quickly as
possible the one word that will save
your life in a hospital we go to the
centerfold this was August of 2011 you
go to the
centerfold remember this is not me this
is Newsweek magazine not me
me here's the
patient here's the
patient and you can see he's in his
hospital gown Barefoot in the hospital
which is probably a no no all the germs
all over the floor and so he's saying no
now we have this new experimental drug
we want to give you no we want to give
you a CAT scan no uh it's time for you
know to go get an enema
no I'm going to get two or three you
know other opinions before I let you do
something weird to
me that alone will save your life
because you're learning them that you're
not just another piece of baggage that
they can just throw around and they're
going to have to be a little careful
with you right now why is he doing that
I mean what is he afraid of why is this
guy terrified why is he screaming no in
the
hospitalti now here are eight
Specialists and surgeons and an
anesthesiologist coming at him now they
look like they're there to as my dad
used to say hip
him no they're not there to hip
him they're there to get into his
insurance
policy they all want a piece of the
action now because they're all hungry
because all the jobs went away nobody's
got health benefits anymore so these
doctors are now starving to death and so
they're shouldering each other out
competing with each other to get their
fingernails into you before the other
doctor gets in there
that's what this picture shows you right
now this is not me this is Newsweek
magazine I just thought that was very
profound look at those
hands I want your money I want your
insurance give me your credit card I'll
take your credit card I mean you go in
for help even your unconscious the first
thing you say you're unconscious they
say what kind of insurance do you have
now here's another problem we have 80
million baby boomers coming
along last year the first 5 million of
them hit Social Security and the reason
why we have all
these lawmakers scaring around
regardless of policy or
party like cockroaches when you turn the
light on because they all took all the
money out of social security so when
Social Security first started 70 people
were supporting one retiree today it's
one person supporting 70 retirees and
it's unsustainable what makes it worse
is all the elected officials have taken
the money out of your Social Security
file there's no money there anymore to
build bridges of nowhere to widen
highways that have no traffic on them so
they can say during the re-election
thing I brought home 500 jobs last four
years and I want you to vote for me to
get me back in they used your money your
Social Security money to get that those
jobs okay so we have a problem so what
what is is the basic problem here why is
the medical system collapsing why are we
in real trouble here how do we remember
that
three-way election presidential election
back in 1992 old Bush 41 Billy Clinton
and Ross perau remember that some of old
enough remember that now want you think
about this very seriously because it was
a very profound election because the
political football of the time was
NAFTA
NAFTA some people call it NAFTA Shafta
and the the discourse between old Bush
41 and Billy Clinton was how to best use
NAFTA to save you know America so we can
get more of our products out into the
world that was kind of their concept
well Ross perau with his big elephant
ears and his whiny little Texas accent
well if anybody signs NAFTA you're going
to hear this giant second sound as all
the jobs leave
America has anybody seen that story
Rewritten or resurfaced or brought up
saying you know Ros perau predicted this
1992 and it's just
happened now why did that happen well
when they signed that that law gave
industry permission to get tax breaks
for hiring people outside the country
that's what NAFTA did gave them
permission to get legal tax breaks for
hiring people out of this country and
they immediately took all the
manufacturing and assembly jobs out of
this country because they didn't have to
supply medical
benefits that's what NAFTA did and Ross
perau warned about it and everybody oh
he's a nut where's American jobs going
to go well they went out of this country
as he predicted in
1992 so we have a huge problem here no
more medical benefits doctors are
starving
now doctors are starving yep and here's
one of the consequences they're kicking
out Medicare patients they're not going
to take care of Medicare patients
anymore okay so they're kicking them out
starting January 1st and also people who
were on fixed income didn't have any
medical care would go into emergency
rooms and they would use the coffee the
emergency they walk around the air
conditioned uh building you know during
the summertime and the heated building
during the winter time to get their
exercise if they they want to get their
blood pressure taken in their blood um
sugar check so they didn't have to buy
the kit and pay for the little strips
and everything and the hospital would
then send the bill to Medicare and
Medicaid who would pay it well they're
broke now cuz nobody's putting any money
in there and there's only one working
person taking care of 70 retirees are on
welfare or on unemployment and so
they've cut it down to instead of 3 days
a week you're able to come to the
hospital emergency room now you can only
do 10 days a year in Florida in excuse
me in Hawaii in Florida it's 45 days
Mississippi is 30 days Arkansas 24 days
Al uh Alabama 16 days most of the states
are falling in 10 to 15 days as the
limit if you want to be in a hospital
longer than 10 or 15 days you got to pay
them cash on the front end now they're
not not billing anybody
okay baby
boomers
again this came out two months ago
September this year there's an AARP
report 15.6 million baby boomers 15.6
million Baby Boomers in the last two
years went from being middle class to
below poverty they went from a
two-income family to one income family
they went from a two income family to a
no-income family there's been 5 million
houses foreclosed upon and people who
are good Americans who paid their
mortgages until they got laid off okay
that's all because the NAFTA allowed
these companies to ship the jobs out and
get tax breaks for hiring people outside
this
country we're the only crazy people who
do such things no other country in the
world does this
you all heard of these censuses that get
taken every 10 years have a census
that's done every 10 years and right now
we're the third largest population in
the world China is 1.8 billion
people India is 1.2 billion and we're
300 million we're like 1if the size of
of China I guarantee you the next 10
years we won't be number three anymore
because all these third world countries
now with all this economy and new money
from all our jobs going over there guess
what they're being able to buy better
food and so forth and they're having
more babies 20 babies per family
now 20 babies per family you know 20
different pregnancies not they're not
having litters or you
know okay now to me though the most
important piece of that that census was
this they said the average black man in
America lives be 62 the average white
man in America lives be 75 and the
average Hispanic man lives to be
80.6 now wait a minute all the other
surveys said that only wealthy people
live the longest the most educated
people live the longest well the
Hispanics have 28.6% unemployment they
have the least amount of Education of
any ethnic group in the United States
they get paid the least they're willing
to take a lot of these jobs and picking
stuff in the field for $3 an hour and
all that kind of stuff so none of this
fits so what's going on here what was
discovered is
this because the blacks have been told
incorrectly and fraudulently that all
their diseases like diabetes and high
blood pressure arthritis and cancer and
obesity is due to genetics they got the
terrible black Gene if you marry the
medical system and use our pills and
potions and use our surgeries we'll be
able to squeeze a couple more years of
life for you out of this terrible black
Jean stick with us we'll help
and so they've overused the medical
system and been killed more often by
contrast Hispanics are still using
Grandma's home remedies and do not use a
medical
system and so they're not killed as
often this is pretty revealing when you
think about
it now as I told you earlier cholesterol
does not cause any disease what is the
normal blood cholesterol level for human
beings 20 let's see here it' be 220 to
270 is normal 220 to 270 is normal but
every doctor will tell you that's too
high because they know you can't get
below that with diet and exercise
that'll give them an excuse to write
your prescription for cholesterol luring
drugs and then they get a little
Kickback every time you fulfill a
prescription you don't think they have
incentives to do that even their staff
gets caviar and stakes and all that kind
of stuff every the drug companies come
in there and buy really high-end food
for these people and buy them tickets to
Disneyland and all that kind of stuff to
the staff for the clinics so they're not
completely clean either well this is
what causes blocked arteries not
cholesterol how many of you heard of
trans fatty acids okay trans fatty acids
that's oxidized oils if you don't know
what an oxidized oil is take an apple of
any kind Gayla Apple Granny Smith you
know whatever cut the Apple in half turn
the cut Sur St come back in an hour and
look at it what's happened to that
pearly white flesh of that apple in that
hour it's turned brown everybody knows
that well that's the oils in that Apple
oxidizing and turning brown now you know
in an apple there's not much oil there's
0.00000000 1% oil and you can see it
with your naked eye oxidizing in just a
few
moments well every oil you use even old
nuts you go from a bulk food store and
you buy some nuts you take them home you
taste them kind of
old the oils and the fats in that nut
has oxidized turned into a trans fatty
acids it'll blug your arteries and kill
you now 1971 I wrote the first article
on this subject because when you do
thousands of autops you can ask the data
any question you want right so the
question I asked
was who are what individuals have the
worst plugged arteries not from blood
clots but from scar tissue and
cholesterol and sat fat and plaque and
that kind of stuff vegans are
mediators with special stains to look at
cholesterol and saturated fat and scar
tissue and calcium guess who had the
worst plugged arteries vegans or
mediators
vegans because they put oil on
everything olive oil coconut oil sesame
seed oil sunflower seed oil and it all
oxidizes clog their arteries that's why
there's no flourishing colonies of
second and third generation vegans
vegans with all these Rosy cheek kids
running around it's a political
statement not a good nutritional plan
now if you want to be a successful vegan
you got to supplement within 90
essential nutrients I have lots of
successful vegans who are on my program
these guys are all martial arts guys are
6'4 240 lbs and they can knock this
building down without even hitting the
building just moving their hand the
whole building falls down these guys but
they've been with me for 25 years
supplementing with the 90 essential
nutrients you'll see why that's
important even for vegans today okay so
it's fried foods it's processed Meats
with nitrates nitrites oils such as
margarin mayonnaise s dressings cooking
oils that clog Our
arteries now when I was a kid we didn't
have salad dressings we didn't have any
salad
dressings what we did was for a salad
they didn't pluck the leaves off of
things and make a salad out of it we had
a wedge of a head of lettuce or a wedge
of a head of cabbage some of you may
remember that and my grandmother would
take pickled beets and Grate them onto
that cabbage that little wedge of
cabbage she'd grate some
cheese right she'd sprinkle it with some
cracked
peppercorns and that's how we ate our
salads that was our salad there was no
such thing as a salad dressing well when
the boys came home from Europe in the
second world war everybody wanted olive
oil like they used in Italy and
Greece that's how this began to happen
so what we're doing now is a very short
it's only like 60 years old it's not
like it's been our entire history of
human beings I mean I guarantee you
cavemen didn't have crafts salad
dressing or Wishbone salad
dressing they didn't drink olive oil
because going out of style they didn't
cook in
it it's not only Fried Chicken but it's
also fried fish Captain D Is Not
Innocent well my wife and I and my my
dear wife is a microsurgeon who taught
at Harvard Medical School I actually met
her at the Texas Medical Center where
she was working with Dei and kulie uh
two great heart transplant surgeons I
met her there and she and I together
over the last 10 years put together this
book called immortality there's some of
those out there in the hall immortality
we spent 10 years looking at the top 20
longevity cultures on Earth trying to
find out why they did better than us now
the amazing thing about this ladies and
gentlemen when we did this research we
took the data from National Geographic
we took it from anthropology uh studies
and anthropology journals and big
universities cuz we didn't want to do it
oursel it would take 50 years it would
take millions and billions of dollars
and nobody would believe us anyway so we
took the data from these big
universities and and um uh from the
National Geographic we credit them for
that source of information but we
rearranged it in such a way that you can
see a picture now where before there
just a scattered article here a
scattered article there we put it all
together what we found out about the top
20 longevity cultures is this number one
they're all third rule cultures they're
illiterate they have no access to
doctors clinics or hospitals
remember the
Hispanics they don't use the medical
system okay they don't have
roads they don't have um
Pharmaceuticals they don't have private
insurance or government insurance if you
looked on a chart a flow chart of the
places on Earth that had everything
you'd want for medical care you would
never go to these top 20 places for
longevity because they don't have any
medical care of any
kind grandma is the medical care
right so there's 25 common threads these
people have they have first of all 40
times 100s we do they have 40 times 40
times 100 olds we do no doctors they
have 40 times 100s we do these people
have 100 old per 250 of their population
according to Harvard Medical School we
have 100 old per
10,000 these people live to be an
average a 90 and health away we live to
be 75 and a sickly away in the
average so what's going on here well we
took the top five we thought was the top
five of these uh 25 common threads we
put them as icons on the cover of the
book here you if you understand these
five things you'll add 25 to 50
healthful years of your life and you'll
never even have to read the book so I'm
going to explain them to you because
they're that valuable first of all how
many of you ever gone to your
grandparents house your parents house
and they still had a wood stove anybody
remember those days when they had wood
stoves what did they do with the ashes
every morning where did the wood ashes
go every morning they went where in the
garden they went in the garden now wood
ashes are not ashes that's a misnomer
the wood ashes are actually the minerals
that are left when you burn away the
carbon in the wood sometimes if you pull
the damper down and shut off the air
supply the fire will smold or cold
during the night and you might have a
little bit of carbon in there around the
edge it might look black or gray but
pure quote wood ashes unquote are really
just powdered minerals are left when you
burn away the carbon in the
wood now these plant minerals would go
out in the garden and the okra and the
tomatoes and the onions and garlic and
the sweet potatoes and squash and corn
and cucumbers and all the other stuff
you grow in the garden would suck these
minerals up and you'd eat the the the
vegetables and Grains and you get your
minerals in that fashion now how many of
you are still eating totally out of your
garden do not go to a grocery store and
you're still putting your wood ashes
into your garden what did you replace
that with
nothing that's why you're in trouble
that's why these people have 40 times
100 as we
do then there's another source of
minerals we used to
have and I I like to to express this to
you using an old ancient Dutch fairy
tale Jack and the
beant remember Jack and the beanock you
know it's a Dutch fairy tale when you
hear the words Fifi F I smell the blood
of an
Englishman be he alive or be he dead
I'll grind his bones to make my bread
how many of are still putting bone meal
in your bread oops Houston we have a
problem no more plant minerals no more
bone
meal bread today is nothing nothing but
calories there's no nutrition in bread
anymore it's just
calories bread in the old days had
minerals from wood ashes and from bone
meal they all get their 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids they'll get it different
ways because they're all different
cultures they have no genetic
relationship to each other we'll go into
some details there in a
moment they have calor restricted diets
calor restricted diets they don't know
the the science behind this because
they're all therbal they're illiterate
they they haven't read anything on
calorie restricted diets yet they all
live in a calor restricted diet because
they're poor they can only afford 900
calories a day Americans according to
the Harvard Medical School consumes
anywhere from 2,800 to 3200 calories a
day per person we're we're taking in
three times the calories a day these
people
do then they don't eat any of the bad
stuff no fried foods of any kind no
carbonated drinks no sugar now it's not
that they wouldn't eat those things if
they available but who's going to build
a drive-thru to sell Kentucky Fried
Chicken in Mountain Dew when the only
thing coming through that drive-through
is going to be some illiterate guy in a
donkey that doesn't work for drive-thru
okay so just because it's not available
by default they don't eat the bad
stuff lastly the top five of these 25
common threads of these long- lived
peoples is they take in 20 times and 50
times the antioxidants we do how many
you heard of the super Juice is like no
P things like asai Berry Goji
mangustin um black New Zealand currant
pomegranate all that kind of stuff right
well all of these juices and and exotic
fruits come from these long liveed
places and people say well look at that
they're they're eating that mangotin
that must be it that must be their
secret so they bring it here and make it
a product and everybody buy it and after
a couple years and all their friends
have died taking the stuff they stopped
taking
it because there's 25 common threads you
have to take together you just take the
Super juices by themselves you add 30
seconds to your life you need all the
other things to make it work it's kind
of like spending $50,000 for a Mercedes
and walking out only with a steering
wheel and walking from here to New York
in the snow and the sleet and the rain
and the cold with a steering wheel are
you going to be comfortable with that no
I don't think so okay so here's the
problem how many you heard of res
veratrol anybody hear res veratrol I can
tell this is Red Wine Country okay this
is the stuff found in red wine and red
grapes skin red grape seeds that is
credited with the French long life and
the reduced risk of cancer and cancer
and and heart disease and so on is this
Resveratrol there's 200 companies that
sell Resveratrol products in America
because there's 80 million baby boomers
who all want to live a long time is is
known as the anti-aging substance so
baby boomers are very very interested in
Resveratrol we wanted to get into that
market with our program but we want to
give people value add we wanted them to
say well the only choice we have is
Wallock right because his is different
and so what we did we looked through
these top 20 longevity cultures in
addition to Res verol they're all taking
in also turmeric ctin as spices and and
things in their food right and so we
added the two American cson into our
cell Shield rtq R for resol t for
tumeric and Q for coron no extra cost
same price as everybody else's res TR
alone but we value added the other two
things now if you take two capsules of
all these other Resveratrol products per
day you're going to get the amount of
Resveratrol and one 6 ounce glass of red
wine that's very respectable because
it's only found in red wine very very
tiny amounts but we wanted to do again
value added we wanted people to say well
the only one we can take the only right
one is is walls and so the same two
capsules of our res verol product our
rtq you get the amount of resir trol not
the amount in one glass of 6 oz Red a
glass of red wine but the amount in 294
glasses of red wine same price so now
you're getting two American ctin Plus
instead of one glass of red wine per two
capsules you're getting 294 glasses of
red wine you don't have to worry about
DUIs because there's no alcohol in
it I take six of those capsules a day so
daily I'm getting the amount of resir
trol you find in 900 glasses of red wine
a day now why am I doing that cuz
politically I cannot die any younger
than
300 cuz I were if I were to die at 200
medical doctors would say well see we
told you he'd
die he only lived to be 200 he'd been
taking all those vitamins minerals all
these years and he only lived to be
200 so I have to be a little extreme
here now how do you remember art link
letter anybody here remember art link
letter now he died May of last year at
97 years of
age he began taking mixing bowls full of
vitamins minerals not mine because mine
weren't available back then but in 1933
he started taking mixing bowls full of
vitamins minerals because he read a book
called Lost Horizon written by James
Hilton it was kind of a historical novel
had a lot of Truth in it but he kind of
Hollywood eyes some of it
and um art read that book and he got
excited about it how many you heard a
lil or a mdin B7 it's kind of like the
apricot pit stuff that's one of the
alternative things for treating cancer
and preventing cancer well it came from
the hanzas in the hza valley of Northern
Pakistan right on the Chinese border and
that was one of the things that it was
attributing to their long life was this
um this apricot pits that had the igin
or Lil in it so he began to eat apricot
pits and he drank the red wine and he
put the wood ashes and minerals into his
food and so on and he died at 97 that's
pretty good and he was lecturing two
weekends a month um until a month before
he died wow that's pretty good because
because he was taking in all these
nutrients since the time since
1933 let's look at a couple more and see
how long they lived and why this little
gal here Margaret Hardy of Irish a
extract you know Hardy The Hardy Boys
novels and so on um this is a picture of
her less than 2 years of age in 2010 she
turned 100 years of age and it was a big
story in this little mag azine from
miske Nevada because this town of miske
Nevada turned 100 years old at the same
time so it's kind of a nice human
interest story woman turns a 100 years
old she was born the day that the town
was incorporated and so on and if you go
to a nursing home or somebody's home
where the relative just turned 100
invariably reporters only get a
paragraph of information they don't like
to go after those things because they
feel they're wasting their time they're
not going to get much they would say
okay Grandma Hardy what did you do to
live be hund and she would say something
like I just keep on
breathing now what kind of useful
information is that you're getting
nothing I mean you know we have paid her
health care for 30 years and that's all
we get she keeps on breathing that's not
much information well because she was
born in the northwest corner of Nevada
where they don't have electricity you
know back a hundred years ago and they
didn't have natural gas and propane and
so forth you know because of of European
extract they got a mineral Source from
two places one was wood ashes
in their food and in their Garden they
had bone meal so you know that just
because that's what the Irish did back
in those days but also because this is a
long birthday announcement in this
paragraph there's very interesting stuff
her family farmed the typical products
grown by others in the valley like
pomegranates she was getting a super
Juice a hundred years ago we're just
discovering that now so where do those I
mean pomegranates come from China so
how' that happen well the Union Pacific
Railroad went right through
M Nevada and so the Chinese built the um
railroad from San Francisco to where it
met the Irish coming from the East Coast
right and went right through Mis Nevada
and here's these Chinese boys with their
right hand driving steel and the left
hand they're eating pomegranates because
grandma sent them to the United States
to earn their fortune and eating
pomegranat because they don't know the
biochemistry but the Chinese know that
if you eat pomegranat you're going to
live a long time they've known this for
thousands of years so it's a kind of a
long live thing may you live a years and
they give you a basket of pomegranates
right so she's getting pomegranate juice
and pomegranate fruit she's getting the
antioxidants in there also there's
enough water there for them to have a
Vineyard and they made red wine which
they sold um in the various farmers
markets and they also made raisins and
sold them commercially so she's getting
Resveratrol she got Resveratrol she got
the super juices from the pomegranates
she got her wood ashes and her bone meal
that's why Margaret Hardy lived to be a
100 not because because she kept on
breathing now a medical doctor could
read that article and wouldn't see all
that in there he would just find it kind
of a cute little story but now you know
more about anti-aging than medical
doctors
do and so you cannot let them take
control of your lives because you know
more than they
do this is my favorite obituary it's
very very telling this gal here George G
excuse me this guy this guy George
Francis
died at 112 in December of '08 when he
died he was the oldest man in America
one of the oldest men in the world now
he's illiterate here's his daughter
reading the newspaper to him he's a
black fellow living out in the swamps
Louisiana he was living on croads and
catfish and onions and peppers and all
that kind of stuff no doctor is
illiterate didn't have a job he's out
there trapping muskrats and things like
that right and and no doctors no clinics
and he was born in
1896 and he lived through 19 US
presidents he lived through 19 US
president now
remember every US president had at least
one University degree many of them had
two and three very wealthy people
usually but they had lots of Education
the doctors who take care of presidents
are not the local Country Bumpkin doctor
are very prestigious they have three or
four degrees these people um have been
heads of departments they did a lot of
research projects I mean these are very
very very well respected doctors with
all
that the average lifespan of US
presidents taking JFK out who's
assassinated in his 40s take him out of
there the average lifespan of US
president is
75 here's an IT alerted swamp rat eating
croads not worrying about his
cholesterol he lives be 112 So it beg
begs the question what's more important
good Medical Care expensive Medical Care
are raw materials raw materials will win
as we go through this you'll see that
raw materials will win every time raw
materials will win every time now when
he died the reporters asked his daughter
what did your daddy do to live to be 112
and she said he broke all the rules of
healthy eating with a diet heavy on
Dairy eggs and lard
sandwiches for those who don't know what
a large sandwich is it's made from pig
fat l aard d pig fat he ate nothing but
Dairy eggs and and pig fat sandwiches
along with Crow EDS and onions and
garlic and peppers now remember he's a
Cajun he's a creole he's eating like the
French who ranked third in
longevity so he's eating like the French
he didn't lower his cholesterol he
stayed away from doctors he didn't know
there was such a thing as
cholesterol and he lived be
112 and Ronnie Reagan got Alzheimer
diseas following the doctor's
instructions
the longest living person right now is
alive today she's a woman from Indonesia
who was born in 1853 she's 157 years
old everybody in this room I don't care
if everybody in your family has died at
53 you have the genetic capacity to live
well beyond 100 but you're going to have
to work at
it the ability to live well beyond 100
is only a potential it's a genetic
potential human beings can live well
beyond 100 but you're not going to
accomplish it just doing whatever
doctors say just eat well get everything
you need uhuhuh that's not going to work
let's look at billionaires they can
afford the best doctors they can hire
the entire medical training staff of
every medical school in the United
States to come in take a splinter out of
their finger right whatever the doctor
says they can hire the best chef get the
best food so let's see how well
billionaires do following the doctor's
instructions for's
magazine 2004 came up with a survey they
wanted to know what kills billionaires
they were looking for a BD a
Billionaire's
disease what they found out was that
billionaires and they use the word
killed billionaires are killed by the
same unglamorous things that kill the
rest of us that's because they use the
same doctor as we
do the average lifespan of a billionaire
according to this forb survey is 78 the
average lifespan of a falling down red
wine drunk from Missoula Montana is
75 you don't gain anything in Health and
Longevity by being a billionaire and
having access to information and
expensive
doctors there's never been a billionaire
Liv to be 100 there has never been a
billionaire lived to be 100 and they can
afford the best and most expensive
Medical Care there is and here's his
iller swamp rant from Louisiana lives be
112 are you beginning to get a picture
just like the Hispanics they live almost
20 years longer than black people
because they don't use doctors
[Applause]
hello well seven years later they redid
it because they didn't want to believe
that statistic so Forest magazine did it
again 7 years later 7 years later turns
out to be March of this year March
2011 what they said was in March of 2011
the average age of billionair dropped
from 78 to
66 the average lifespan of a billionaire
dropped 12 years in seven years
following the doctor's
instructions now how many of you would
go out of your way to seek a doctor for
yourself who is bragging that he treats
billionaires I'd chase him off my lawn
with a
hammer I'd be sure to get a claw hammer
so I can inflict more egregious
wounds oh Houston we have a
problem Steve Jobs killed at age
56 one of the most wealthy one of the
most intelligent men in the last of the
20th century in the first part of the
21st century father of the Apple you
know why he called his PC an apple
because he was a fruitarian at that time
he only ate fruit lived on fruit for
about two years he's a fruitarian so he
named his PC apples for that reason iPod
iPhone iPad I this I
that he could afford the best he could
get information from
anywhere in seconds he get the
information and they kill him at age 56
now the story was the father iPad
dies oh what an awful thing just kind of
like an Andy Rooney
story he passed away way he was
killed by a medical system even though
he could afford the best which is what
got him in trouble if he' had gone to
some Shaman in the middle of Central
America he'd still be alive at least
they wouldn't kill
him now I think about it what do you
have to give what drugs you give
somebody when they get an organ
transplant like a liver transplant like
he got you have to have anti-rejection
drugs right immunosuppressant drugs well
as soon as they did the liver transplant
on him he was dead man walking because
what is your best friend when you have
cancer your immune
system Houston we have a
problem they kill they killed Steve Jobs
as sure as the sun comes up every
morning now my favorite Nobel Prize
winner Albert Einstein died at 76 or
something that a turkey Wouldn't Die
from he went to Stanford Medical School
for treatment he was on the department
of physics there at Stanford University
Northern
California he died of a copper
deficiency which caused a ruptured atic
aneurysm he bled to death in seconds at
age 76 there's about 20 different ways
you can die from a copper deficiency all
of which we eliminated in turkeys in
1947 13 years before he died now the
first outward sign of a copper
deficiency is white gray and silver hair
I see a lot of copper deficients in his
room tonight coloring your hair ladies
doesn't count is still
white gra silver underneath you're still
at risk now if you don't die suddenly
when your hair starts turning gray it
could be 2 years old doesn't matter of
age it has nothing to with age you begin
to get a breakdown of the elastic fibers
and collagen and connective tissue in
your body and your face looks like
you've been run over by a
Hummer kind of like Albert Einstein
there now if he were to go to a plastic
surgeon would he get BOTOX in a facelift
or would he get copper he'd get BOTOX in
a facelift wouldn't it well if you don't
die suddenly then you got to break down
the elastic fibers from a copper
deficiency and collagen connective
tissue in your in your blood vessels you
start getting spider veins varicose
veins and
hemorrhoids hemorrhoids are nothing but
vericose veins in a funny place that's
all the hemorrhoids are they're just
varicose veins in a funny place now some
of you like me are old enough to
remember those old black and white
Silent News
reals whatever before the movies you
know in the old days in the late 40s
right after the second World
War I remember seeing pictures of Albert
Einstein walking down the halls of
Stanford University with arm load of
books and papers you know ow ow ow ow ow
ow ow that's because he
had hello he had hemorrhoids he had
hemorrhoids hanging down to his
KNE you tell by looking at his face with
a face like that I guarantee you he had
hemorrhoids hanging down to his
knees and then he got to break down the
elastic fibers in his aarta and he had
ruptured atic Anders and he bled to
death from a copper deficiency something
a turkey wouldn't die from
now in by contrast lonus Pauling who got
two Nobel
prizes his first one of which was for
Research into the nutrition of enzymes
the nutrition of chromosomes and the
nutrition of genes you see a gene won't
do anything by itself it needs
nutritional co-factors to work even
genes need nutrition so he got his Nobel
Prize by by laying that out very clearly
so everybody can understand it and
during his acceptance speech for his
first Nobel Prize and he had two
unshared Nobel prizes only only
accomplished by one other person he said
during his acceptance speech for this
Nobel Prize for researching the the
nutrition of genes chromosomes and
enzymes he said you can trace every
sickness every disease and every ailment
to a mineral deficiency it's very
profound when you think about it now he
started taking mixing bowls full of
vitamins minerals when he was 20 years
old because nutrition was his passion
that's why he studied nutrition
of enzymes chromosomes and
genes and he lived to be
93 now he didn't have access to my stuff
but he took some vitamins and minerals
now doctors have credibility so let's
look at doctors and see how long they
live everybody wants to be a doctor
there's a glass doctor tree doctor Lawn
Doctor right right now right now there's
debt doctors yeah
this pretty typical doctors you know
that they're doctors because they got
their little plastic name tag with their
clinic and Hospital name on it they got
their name on it they got their
stethoscope around their neck I mean
doctors are very insecure I mean they
won't even have sex without their
stethoscope around their
neck they're very
insecure okay now you know these P these
doctors are very happy because they've
just gotten a new patient that's why
they're smiling and the patient had good
credit line
H well these these doctors will not kill
you because they're Rug Doctors
they're
car so when you go when you go into that
rug store that carpet store they're all
running around wearing white coats and
stethoscopes because immediately you
feel I'm in the right place I can be
healed they're even
specialist now these are the ones that
will kill you these are the real thing
the real
deal I mean you think you're get much
sympathy from him I don't think so
he looks like a mortician he doesn't
look like a
doctor now this came out in February
2005 US news world report rated
America's most credible print news
service rated America's most credible
print news service this is not a comic
book this is not me this is the US news
world report okay and February 2005 they
said special health issue who needs
doctors your future physician might not
be a medical doctor he may be better
off now do you think they ran around
town picked up 25 or 30 of these and
made sure that everybody in the waiting
room got one I don't think so I think
they went around town picked them all up
so nobody could get at them right now
what the story was talking about young
ladies like this who is a nurse
practitioner there's Physicians
assistants there's chiropractors there's
um naturopathic doctors there's uh
herbalists there's acupuncturists and
Chinese traditional medical doctors say
at least they won't kill you cuz they
had just discovered the doctors kill
people and they were just so mortified
they made this a cover
article your future physician might not
be a medical doctor and you may be
better
off now how many you know the CVS
Pharmacy and Walmart now are putting
these little One Minute Clinics in now
yep and they're all being manned by PA
Physicians assistants and nurse
practitioners there's no doctors
involved now the Mantra is the physician
assistant is in so the doctor is in
right so CVS Pharmacy has 1,50 of these
right now Walmarts has something like
200 and by the end of this year both of
them are going to have several thousand
of these little One Minute
Clinics what they do is they give you a
lot of free advice and you walk 3et and
you get your prescription that they just
gave you no office call
and these are to get all these seniors
who don't have access to the emergency
rooms anymore because the state's
shutting all that down they can't go in
there anymore unless they put up cash in
the front end so all these little old
ladies and little old gentlemen who
don't have access to Medical Care are
now going to go to CVS Pharmacy and
Walmarts that's a good thing I don't
like drugs very much but that's a good
thing because a PA won't kill them as
often as a doctor will a nurse
practitioner won't kill them as often as
a doctor
will also one of the things we have and
you can make sure you got your name and
address and phone number and email out
there we give away free pharmacy
discount cards you can get up to an 85%
discount on all Pharmaceuticals for your
dog and yourself they never expire these
cards never expire you get up to a 60%
discount for all lab work for your dog
and yourself and a flat 35% discount for
hearing aids the card never expires you
can have everybody in your family your
block in your church use the same card
number and we give them to you for free
now you may not I don't use
Pharmaceuticals but if you and you might
not use pharmacetical by bet you have a
Granddad or a mom or an auntie or
somebody who uses pharmaceutical right
why not give them an 85% discount ask
for your free pharmaceutical discount
card it's just for showing up here we're
going to be good to you guys now let's
see how long Doctors live the original
audio cassette tape that came out in
1993 was based on a little survey I did
on primary care physicians and family
doctors cuz I started seeing obituaries
and newspapers of doctors 28 years old
35 years old 42 years old I said that's
really weird how long did Doctors live
so I went to the medical Library just
grabbed a handful of the journal
American Medical Association just got
the first 200 you know even number first
200 of obituaries added up the age
divided by 200 got 57.6 rounded up to to
um 58 to give him the benefit of Doubt
and I said why would anybody want to go
to a group of people to learn how to
live to be 120 when that group of people
only lives to be
58 I mean everybody was giving their
doctors these audio cetes and doctors
were calling me and threatening me with
murder I was just
the things were going on over that he
said well wallik lying that can't be so
they went and did their own study this
is their study came out in 1999 mine
came out in
1993 six years later here's what they
said wck lied the average primary care
physician and family practitioner does
not die at 58 like he says we die at
56 now they're so eager to show that my
statistics were incorrect that they
didn't care that their statistics showed
that they died two years younger than I
said and so I'm here to happily
apologize to you that I gave him to too
many years in my
survey why would you go to anybody for
advice on longevity whose average
lifespan is 56 according to their own
survey they're dumber than
stumps okay arm is new
enemy just leave live clean no fried
foods no margins no cooking oils
absolutely no processed Meats with
nitrates nitrites take your Mighty 90
the 90 essential nutrients and the odds
are you won't need any Pharmaceuticals
now I'm 72
chronologically my biological age is 18
I'm an 18-year-old male athlete
biologically and I go to all these trade
shows so I go to these booths I get you
know my free blood taken this and I get
my blood pressure taken for free go into
CVS Pharmacy and get it taken for free
my U resting pulse is 43 when I really
get worked up and angry it rises very
steeply to
45 and then my blood pressure is 121
over
71 and I've never had a a prescription
pharmaceutical okay I've not been sick
the last the first and last time I ever
been to a doctor when I was 9 years old
the first and last time I've ever been
to a doctor with me being the patient
I've been to a doctor to their funerals
cuz my wife saves all these obituaries
for me I go back to Southern California
she got these stack of
obituaries if if they're going to be
buried in the next couple of days I go
to the brave site and I just want to
listen to what everybody saying I never
identify myself as a dead doctor's don't
lie guy
okay now back when I first started doing
this 33 years ago giving 300 free
lectures a
year I could get in an airport and a
little granny a little Granddad would
come up to me with their photo album and
say you want to see my grandkids this's
little Sherry and this little Frankie
and this is Bob and Tom and this is Ruth
they're going to be this they're going
to be that and I just love them to
pieces and here's what they do and this
one plays music and all that well today
this is what granes and grandads look
like they say you want to see my
Pharmaceuticals I said do you have any
grandkids y' got five grandkids can you
name them for me nope can you give me
the scientific names of those 27 Oh yeah
this is flamadiddle riddle schmidle you
know they give you all the scientific
names of all these
things and this guy looks like he's from
h
Lake
Washington or Idaho or something I mean
this this is Idaho
guy this came out in
2006 this is a 2006 this is a annual
number this is a national story not just
a state deaths by medication eror Rising
now they're not talking about the side
effects of drugs they're talking about
the Doctor Who wrote the prescription
made a mistake they're talking about the
pharmaceutical um store the pharmacist
who fulfilled the prescription made a
mistake the person taking the
pharmaceutical may have made a mistake
if you're really a bad luck person all
three came into play right what they
said was each year in America
pharmaceutical medication errors are
tied to 1.5 million fatalities and
injuries every
year why would you on Earth would you
want to take a pharmaceutical
there's an example Marilyn moroe um
Elvis Presley Keith Ledger River Phoenix
and on and on and on all these famous
wealthy people who could get access to
these things and doctors write a
prescription get killed by these things
because they abuse them there's more
people killed every year this just came
out a couple of days ago there's more
people killed every year from
prescription painkillers in America than
from street
drugs there's more people every year in
America die from prescription
painkillers than die from street drugs
we're spending too much money going
after the street dealers we should be
going after the
doctors yeah one of my favorite CDs that
that I made is called dial MD for murder
now now those of you who remember the
movie remember the movie dial M for
Murder I just added one
letter dial MD for Mur you'll love it
because it has all these instances where
doctors really do some crazy things that
kill
people yeah that's one of my favorites
dial MD for murder okay let's talk about
exercise now now whether you believe it
or not how many of you heard that
exercise is good for you now if you
don't raise your hand you're a Lon commi
because I know you've all heard that
right now Jim fix came up with the idea
that Personal Fitness was important back
in the 1960s and that if you just ran
you wouldn't even need to take vitamins
minerals that was his Mantra you look up
in the index of this book The Complete
Book of running which came out in 1977
you look under vitamins it says page so
and so you go to that page and it says
don't take vits minerals just run you
look up the word minerals and there
there's no word minerals in the
index well the the um New York was it
the newspaper there the New York Times
uh actually made this a priority and
they said look everybody needs to read
this book so they made it a New York
Times bestseller endorsed this book it
came out 19 1977 5 years later in 1982 a
beautiful September Day in Vermont 50°
Sunny no wind he's running getting ready
for the Olympics he's going to run the
marathon in the Olympics for as he drops
dead at the 12 mile Mark bam I mean he
drops
dead from a cardiopathy heart attack a
simple deficiency the trace selenium now
I know that cardiopathy heart disease is
caused by a trac metal deficiency call
selenium because I'm a veterinarian
Physicians don't know this so you know
more about cardiomyopathy heart disease
right now than all medical doctors in
America is caused by a deficiency of
selenium how do I know that well my wife
and I went to China and through the
cooperation of the Chinese government we
did 1,200 autopsies on kids under the
age of 10 who died of a cardiopathy
heart attack and there's one province
that has no Slam in the
soil they give slam to all their animals
they don't die of cardiopathy heart
attack but the kids just eat the food
kind of like the Amish they just eat
food grown there locally and they die
these cardiomyopathy heart attacks so we
did 1,200 of these autop in 6
weeks man now the kids the kids over
there now get selenium every day the
teachers give us selenium in school it
stopped it no more cardiopathy heart
disease in
China well when he died in 1982
September 1982 the the New York Times
knew that they had made a huge mistake
the Journal of the American Medical
Association knew they had made a
terrible mistake in endorsing this guy's
book so they came out in October a month
later with sort of like their due
diligence that they should have done
before they endorsed his book The
Journal the American Medical Association
1982 it was an October 1982 while
running a man's risk of heart attack
death increases by a factor of
700% while running a man's risk of heart
attack death increases by a factor of
700% so somebody tells you to go out and
run and exercise are sending you to your
death that sounds kind of rude but
there's a reason for me saying that
you'll see in a moment now you know Ted
Kennedy had a daughter named
carara for eight years before her death
in September of
2011 she ran five miles a day seven days
a week and then she'd go to this health
club and she'd swim for an hour and cool
down and relax and go to the spa and all
kind of stuff on this fateful day in
September 2011 she dies at age 51 from a
cardiopathy heart attack bam she was
dead now do you think the owner of that
health food place that that Spa that
that health club is going to take a sign
saying we want you to join our health
club because Cara worked out
here no because everybody says no no no
she died
there she died in your health club she
died in your fitness center at age 51
she was a
billionaire there's a reason for this
I'm going to tell you in a minute but I
want you to ponder on this for a
minute are there any sports fans in here
only a few H let me ask you another way
are there any football fans in here okay
that's a little better okay now how you
remember in February and March of this
year there's this big thing going on
about football players having head
injuries and concussions and they were
planning on changing the rules of
blocking and tackling and they want to
put more padding in the helmet and
redesign everything remember that well
the same thing was going on up in Canada
the sports medicine doctors there as
they were going through all the DAT oh
my
gosh professional football players only
only live to be 55 on the
average and so the the life insurance
company said wait a minute we're losing
a lot of money then we need to Triple we
need to Triple Thee the life insurance
premiums for these guys because we we
figured everything out that they live to
be 75 like everybody else so they
refigured it and they said that figure
55 is not correct you know the actuaries
that crunch the numbers they said the
average football player both the United
States and Canada do not live to be 55
they they live to be
51 I'm man I football
player I wrestled for the University of
Missouri I only weighed 123 lbs and in
that workout room in that weight room
were all these big 250 320b football
players back you know in the day in the
early well in the early 60s late 50s and
they used to laugh these football
players used to laugh at the
bodybuilders and who was standing in
front of the mirror all the time you
know posing and looking at their muscles
CU they had to to to win these contests
they had to have perfect Symmetry and
their right bicep head to be the same
size as her left bicep all that kind of
stuff and they're popping vitamin and
middle pills like
crazy and these big football players are
drinking protein drinks and they're
drinking
cocacola we're the real men here look
look at those those guys weightlifting
and taking all en bi
minerals and they died
51 football players because they live on
Gatorade
here's
why when you exercise or even do
physical work you sweat don't you if
somebody loves you when you leave the
house they say here honey take some
water with you so you can rehydrate
right it's going to be hot outside
you're going be sweating make sure you
take plenty of water well that's what
kills
you that's what kills you and here's why
when you sweat you're not sweating out
water you're sweating out a soup
contains all 90 essential nutrients 16
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatties acids
and you're replacing that soup with
water if you have a car ladies and
gentlemen that's burning a quarter oil a
week would you replace that qu oil with
water no no that engine is going to burn
up by the second week yeah that's what's
happening when you're just drinking
water I'm a purist I just drink
water bam you're
dead because you're sweating out of soup
and you have to replace the soup
with
soup now Reggie Lewis 28-year old
captain of the Boston Celtics 1994 they
were playing a a playoff game against
the Charlotte Hornets today the
Charlotte
Bobcats he collapses during the game
with a card the heart attack didn't die
he survived it he he collapsed as he's
unconscious and he was a very wonderful
young man 28 years old a gentleman this
guy never jumped in the stands and beat
up the paying customers you know one of
the last guys in the NBA who is a
gentleman right and so the Celtics hired
the top 20 no no let me back that up
they hired yeah the top 12 cardiologists
from around the world the top 12
Cardiology from around the world they
called it the dream team of Cardiology
and they um paid them a million dollars
each to find a heart from a 18-year-old
male athlete who had died from a head
injury a car wreck transplant that heart
into Reggie get him back on the court
they're going to give him 10 extra years
on the court because they're going to
give him a heart from a 18-year-old
instead of a 28-year-old right well
while they were arguing who's going to
be the captain of this dream team of
Cardiology to take care of Reggie and be
famous for transplanting the heart he
dies of his second cardiopathy heart
attack because nobody gave him 50 cents
a day worth of
selenium because you see Doctors medical
doctors don't know that cardiopathy
heart disease is a selenium
deficiency well the guy who was destined
to be the captain of that dream team of
Cardiology was one Dr W Thom Thomas
Nessa Dr Nessa was the chairman of the
Department of Cardiology at Harvard
Medical School he taught medical
students Cardiology he taught medical
doctors who specialize in cardiology
Cardiology at their continuing education
meetings right so they could keep their
licenses he ran the Boston marathon
every year for 20 years himself so he
would be doing what he was asking his
patients to do
exercise also he was the cardiologist
for the NBA the National Basketball
Association and he was the cardiologist
for the Celtics well a year and a half
after Reggie died from a cardiopathy
heart attack at age 48 Dr W Thomas Nessa
died of the same caught him up of the
heart attack bam I mean he was
dead if I was his family I'd be
embarrassed to tears this guy had to be
Dumber in a box of rocks he's supposed
to be the premier cardiologist in the
world and he dies of 48 of a heart
attack I guarantee you that all his
patients said wasn't a terrible that Dr
Nessa died and then they just kept on
doing what he said to
do now I don't have a cardiologist
remember I told you I don't have doctors
don't take any prescription medications
but if he were my cardiologist and he
said okay wall you're 72 years old now I
need you to give up salt cuz I'm worried
about your blood pressure I'd run around
Missoula and I'd collect every salt
shaker from every restaurant and hotel I
leave a $5 bill so I wasn't stealing
anything and um I'd take it home I'd go
to Every Health Hood store I get every
packaged bag bottle and box of Himalayan
salt Celtic salt Celtic salt sea salt I
go to Every grocery store and get every
box and canister Morton salt Morton salt
with the iine i' take it home and I
build a a twoot frame around my bed i'
fill that frame with all the salt i' get
naked and I wiggle around in there till
the salt covered me while I slept I have
nurses come in at night while I'm asleep
and install three IVs in each arm with
saline solution I get three liters in
each arm every night of saline solution
with salt water I wake up in the morning
I give myself a salt enema I'd brush my
teeth wash my hair and take a bath in
salt
water and then on the weekends I'd run
around naked like crazy John the Baptist
throwing salt everywhere to make sure
everybody knew the value of salt that's
right and then if he said eggs are bad
for because the cholesterol I eat 25
eggs a day if he
said
exercise I'd go home I'd lay in that
salt bed and I wouldn't even blink cuz I
wouldn't do anything that resembled
motion cuz I wouldn't want to wind up
like Dr Nessa
dead
dead you got it baby okay now this is a
tragic story this scal here rala Pierce
19 years old 6'5 she could do the Air
Jordan thing and she was courted by
every University and every woman's
professional basketball team in the
world they're all putting millions of
dollars in trust funds for her telling
her in the 21st century she was going to
be the the woman athlete of the 21st
century maybe Of All Times uh she'd be a
billionaire because of all her line of
clothing and sports equipment and
clothing and and things like beauty
products and so on and she chose to go
with Florida State University for two
years cuz she got a from them she got a
academic as well as an athletic
scholarship and she said look when I'm
21 years old two years down the line I
will have had time to study the
franchise decide which one I'm going to
join right well halfway through a
freshman you're still aged 19 years old
she drops dead bam she drops dead from
ruptured atic anism from a copper
deficiency just like Albert Einstein
because you see oh they say it's genetic
because doctors are dumb because she's
tall yes exactly
yeah and
so all she had to do was supplement with
a 90 but she didn't because she had a
personal physician she had a team
physician she had team because of the
University they had a nutritionist
personal trainer and she dies at 19
years of age from a nutritional
deficiency because she's sweating out of
soup and drinking
Gatorade I mean who came up with
Gatorade Florida State
and then in March of this year there's a
kid by the name of Wes Leonard from
fenville high school during a in
Michigan in a in a semi-finals playoff
against Holland Michigan right on the
Eastern shores of Lake Michigan they're
having the semi-finals game and at the
end of the buzzer the end of the game
was 5555 so prophetically they had to do
a SE a sudden death playoff to find out
who's going to win to to advance to the
finals
so he gets the tip off takes 10 Giant
Steps down the court slams dunk the ball
in and they win 57 55 within 10 seconds
after him getting the tip off this is 3
seconds before he died this picture he's
faing the camera his teammates are so
excited they're lifting him up to his
shoulders before they get him on his
shoulders he falls back dead from a
cardiopathy heart attack a simple
deficiency of the Trac selenium now
here's what makes me very angry the
medical
examiner the the the guy guy who did the
autopsy on West Leonard said his death
could not be easily explained that he
died of a selenium deficiency he died of
a cardiopathy heart attack he died of a
selum
deficiency and this guy doesn't know
enough about nutrition and he's a
certified licensed medical examiner and
he done no squat because he didn't say
on there if everybody takes selenium
they wouldn't die like this there'll be
another 100,000 Kids In America die
every
year he had the chance it was National
story this is what doctors want you to
believe they could detect the genetic
defect if they could only do more
electroc cardiograms and this is West
Leonard
again a couple of days
later casually fenville Michigan West
lard died after game from a card heart
attack a slam
deficiency he see want more electric
cardiogram so they can screen for heart
defects and cause sudden death you can
take an electrocardiogram 3 seconds
before you die from a um cardiopathy
heart attack from a sleam deficiency you
won't detect
it it's not detectable with an electroc
cardiogram they are
dumb okay here's a 16-year-old girl who
died of a cardiomyopathy heart attack
does always be boys Freemont High School
in Los Angeles she's a cheerleader I
mean she's the best one she's doing back
flips running up and down jumping up and
down cute little girl
dies of a cardiopathy heart attack a
slam deficiency 16 years
old now how many of you remember a guy
by the name of Jack
laain guy he wasn't the juice guy he was
not the Juice Guy Jay cordish was the
juw man how many Remember Jay cordish
big white eyebrows Jay cordish was the
juice man for 50 years he sold juicers
on TV he made literally hundreds of
millions of dollars selling juice
machines on TV it's only when he retired
Jack Lane kind of filled in the last 5
years before he died he was not the juw
man and he never used the word Juiceman
because Jay cordish would have sued him
right Jay cish was a juic man well he
died at 96 the January 23rd of this year
died at 96 he began taking mixing bowls
full of vitamins
minerals when he was 12 years old cuz he
wanted to be Mr America and Mr Universe
and he accomplished at age 21 and he
took mixing bowls full of vitamins
minerals not mine because he started
taking them a long time ago right ours
weren't available then and he started
taking
them every day since he was like 12
years old what is the common thread
between artlink letter lonus paully and
Jack L Lane they all took vitamins and
minerals since they were
kids now let's see the football players
died
51 we're in the game torade and Arizona
Tea and
water see the
difference you take the mighty 90 we
call it some people call it the almighty
90 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
well how do you get that well we have it
out there it's very simple I'll show you
a little bit here very interesting stuff
got just about I don't know few more
slides left they're going to give away a
lot of things do the drawing and then
I'll answer questions for you for an
hour or so and
this fell here theor Ratliff is the
longest playing professional foot excuse
me professional basketball player the
longest playing professional basketball
player Theo Ratliff I met him when he is
playing with the Atlanta Hawks at age 28
his career was over because he had bone
to- bone arthritis and in both knees the
carage popped off his right hip and he
had to have it surgically stapled back
down and he was so fragile he had
osteoporosis so bad at age 28 he caught
a pass during an NBA official game it
broke his wrist just catching a pass
from a teammate broke his wrist so the
arthop surgeons for the Atlanta Hawks
examined him and said his career is over
he can't you know he can't take the bump
bump and hit and all that kind of bump
and run in professional basketball so
his career is over well a mutual friend
introduced us and we rebuilt him with
our Mighty 90 the almighty 90 in 90 days
and we built a sports drink for him
which we sell a lot of Cu people love it
tastes good we have four different
flavors and it has 100 nutrients in it
Gatorade has two ours has 100 nutrients
in it same price per serving ours has
100 nutrients theirs has
two okay they do not have copper and
selenium in there ours has copper and
selum plus the other
98 nutrients all right comes in a liquid
concentrate comes in powder and a big
cancer it comes in individual servings
tear off the top POR in the bottle all
right well since his career over and I
rebuilt
him he's made $140 million in contract
since the arthop surgeon has told him
his career was
over now do you think his wife Christina
loves
me she loves me $140 Million
worth now anybody here have a
dog anybody have a dog okay I'm going to
go with this lady
here now what's your dog's name grle
gredle must be a girl yeah now is is she
a
dotion she's a St Bernard a St
Bernard
what huh we live in Montana oh you live
in Montana okay okay so you have this St
Bernard yeah now do you feed this gredle
St Bernard how old is gredle uh believe
it or not she's 12 that's very good no I
do believe it you already kind of
partially answered my question here
she's 12 years old now do you feed
gredle garbage and table scraps or you
feed her dog food no she gets neutr
nuggets she gets nutr nuggets very good
that's why she's 12 years old
now we spent $120 million no no let me
try let me change it we spent $120
billion over the last 100 years
perfecting dog food we've tripled the
lifespan of dogs 60 years ago an old dog
was 8 years old 108 old dog is 25 we
didn't do that with Wonder drugs and
Argan transplants and stem cells and gen
injur protein we did it with Nutri
chunks or whatever you call them right
okay
now why did you feed grle this what is
it Neutra what neutr nuggets neutr
nuggets okay why did you feed gredle
neutr nuggets I mean that's a big dog so
why don't you just give grle garbage and
table scraps what would happened to grle
her brother was allergic to corn and
neutr Nuggets doesn't have any corn okay
so that's that's a good reason okay but
also realistically do you think grle
would live to be 12 years old as she is
now just feeding her table scraps no
she'd Pro no probably not she'd probably
die some weird thing
right and why would you just give a dog
table scraps when you don't know what's
in it and well you have a dog food and
now also do you use a dog food meant for
giant breeds or you just take the $5 bag
no it it's um it's neutr nuggets okay
well what you want to do is see if she
has a dog feeders It's Kind like a
rabbit feeder so she can eat anytime she
wants yeah but what I want you to
understand is if she's getting generic
dog food that's designed for a 50 PB dog
she will not live to be
25 because there's dog food for toy dogs
under 10 pounds there's dog food for
dogs that weigh 30 to 50 pounds there's
dog food for large breeds like like uh
oh German Shepherds and and labs and
then there's dog food for giant breeds
like St Bernard's and um great Dan's
okay so I would urge you to get if
Neutron nuggets has a formulation for
giant breeds I would move over to the
one formulated for giant breeds all
right now a little dog like a Yorkie
could not eat the dog food that gret's
eating because she can't eat enough to
get all the nutrients she needs that's
why the little dogs are teeth tend to
fall out and they get all the heart
disease and all this kind of stuff
because they can't get enough nutrition
for dog food designed for a 50 lb dog
that's why they make dog food for toy
dogs under 10 lbs because there's more
nutrients per pound to feed they do it
by body weight instead of just dog food
all right now here comes the ultimate
question what's your name
ma'am I'm Judy Judy
Judy Judy okay Judy her
name I'm only give money to judies now
you change your name back didn't you
okay so here's the ultimate question
Judy why do we humans eat dog food why
don't we eat dog food why why do we eat
food that will kill a dog why do we eat
food that will kill a dog we make sure a
dog gets dog food that it's better
forarm instead of our food I don't like
the taste of what
she well you're very
[Applause]
smart well I want to send you some A1
sauce to put on
it okay but you get the picture here
don't you we eat food that will kill a
dog we eat food that will kill a dog we
love our dogs so much we food we eat the
food that will kill a dog and we give
the food that will kill a dog to our
kids that's why our kids are not going
to live as long as us now pay attention
here because here comes the bottom lines
you've been sitting here very patiently
and you've been learning some stuff but
here it comes there's about six or seven
slides left and you're going to know
more than doctors know at the end of
this thing which doesn't take much okay
there's 90 essential nutrients required
by all vertebrates it doesn't matter if
you're a hummingbird an elephant a snake
or a human being or a monkey or a turtle
it doesn't matter a salamander if you're
a vertebrae you need the 90 essential
nutrients they're called essential
nutrients ladies and gentlemen for two
reasons number one we cannot make these
things we must consume them every day
either as food or as supplements right
number two if they're missing for a
length of time seconds minutes hours
days weeks months years get horrible
diseases many of which are
life-threatening we need 60 minerals and
you see there's two asteris there
because minerals make up 2/3 of the 90
cenal nutrients so you know it's very
important so we need 160 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids plants cannot
manufacture minerals plants take carbon
dioxide out of the air use the sun's
energy in a process known as
photosynthesis to split the O2 off pump
it out in the environment so we can
breathe make chains out of the carbons
and they make vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids these three um food groups
are carbon chains and plants can make
these but does an orange make all these
things in proper ratios no an orange
makes some vitamin C A little bit of
sugar
that's what oranges make so also you
notice there's no carbohydrates or
sugars in here as essential nutrients
because we can make one of the
definition of an essential nutrient is
you can't make it we can make all the
sugars and carbohydrates we need from
proteins and fats so
carbohydrates and sugars are not
essential nutrients you do not need to
eat them and then you'll be able to cut
your calories in half and double your
lifespan you do not need to eat sugar
and
carbohydrates they're not essential
Nutri nutrients now as I said plants
cannot make minerals and plants only
need three nutrients one element and two
minerals NPK nitrogen phosphorus
potassium to give the farmer the maximum
yields in terms of tons and bushels per
acre and to make good seeds for the Next
Generation we need 60 so if you're
eating a pretty good slice of
organically grown multi-grain bread
you're 57 chart because you're not
putting wood ashes and bone meal in your
bread
anymore that's the problem so you have
to supplement now in dogs we don't care
what nutrition is in the
food we put everything in there
nutritionally they need and then
whatever value they get from the food is
value added we don't depend on
it now nutritional minerals do not occur
in a uniform blanket around the crust of
the earth they occur in veins like
chocolate and chalk rle ice
cream now think about that what that
means now in our national anthem we have
have a phrase in there Amber Wes of
grain now to me this is very exciting
when you see something like this you
know I'm a farm kid and you see this
just warms your heart because we're a
farming Nation our founding fathers were
all Farmers the guys who came up with
the um Declaration of Independence the
Constitution we're all Farmers there's
not a single farmer in our federal
government anymore they're all
lawyers that's one of the reasons why
we're in trouble there's no Farmers
there
right and so we have huge problems here
now but on the other hand we take care
of the world we feed you look at this
you say my gosh we can feed the world
but there's a problem with this because
just in general you know that
nutritional minerals do not occur in
uniform blank around the crust of the
earth plants only need three so you know
there's at least three nutrients here
and so let's say that this row here has
three minerals in it this row over here
has 22 this row has three this row has
16 this row has eight this row over here
has 17 it depends on which Row in the
field that your grain came from how many
minerals are in
it it gets worse than
that this is a satellite picture of
Farmland agricultural land in Southern
California just south of the saltan sea
which is a small version of the Great
Salt Lake this is a salt and sea from
100 miles up a satellite picture and the
the stubble in these fields has been
burnt at the end of the growing season
the end of the harvest season I want you
to look at the the veins in the soil
here is red over here there's some pink
here there's some black there's some
sort of cream color stuff and then
there's um I don't if what you call this
almost like a peeter color there's
yellow and orange and there's gold and
then there's pink stuff again and
there's this Peter stuff again then
there's gray Battleship Gray and there's
pink and yellow and orange and
gold now remember what I told you the
amount of minerals and variety of
minerals in these different veins
is highly different it's not the same so
if you grow a tomato in each one of
these different color zones it's not
going to have the same mineral nutrition
in it it's not going to have the same
vitamin amino acids and fatty acid
nutrition in it because plants need
these mineral raw materials to make the
other stuff as co-actor right and so
there's only one way you can level the
playing field because you go to a
farmers's market and you get a tomato
beautiful looking beef steak tomato
tastes good but you have no earthly idea
how how many minerals are in there now
neutr nuggets that's a gr gets okay
neutr nuggets neutr nuggets being eaten
by a dog in every major city in the
United States will get exactly the same
perfect diet by contrast if you go to a
farmers's market and just outside those
cities and you're eating bread made from
local grain there's no two loaves of
bread in America that are going to be
the same when it comes to nutritional
minerals in there there's only one way
that you can level a playing field so
that your diet is perfect and better yet
more importantly the diet of your kids
and grandkids is more perfect you have
to supplement now this is what makes us
different this is an ancient plant
compost this is not rock this beige
brown material here you stick your hand
in there it's like coffee grounds looks
like coffee grounds has the same
consistency as coffee grounds you can
run it through a spreader we sell liquid
for fol your feeding for Gardens and and
big large farm prises but this is where
we get our minerals for animals and
people okay this has 77 certified
organic plant minerals in it it's been
certified organic every year for 35
years nobody else has this this is the
core of all of our programs for the 9900
different diseases we can treat we can
prevent we can
reverse this is what makes us different
now you get a one a day
multiple like one a day Centrum Silver
for women Centrum Silver for men the may
have 28 to 32 nutrients in there not
90 the the um minerals might only have
12 instead of 60 and do they have 100%
of each one of those minerals no they
have 20% of the minimum data requirement
20% of the minimum data requirement 5%
of the minimum data requirement 2% of
the minimum data requirement because
they're
assuming that there's something in the
food you're eating well that's backwards
you should assume there's nothing in
there and then you supplement properly
and then everything that is in the food
is just value
added they got it backwards we treat our
dogs better than we treat our
kids we're in big trouble as a
result and of course shame on the
doctors because they encourage all that
kind of stuff now I also have doctors
who would say You' probably heard this
yourself oh Wall come on there's no
evidence you can prevent and cure
disease like with vitamins minerals we
believe in science things that have been
proven there's no
proof that you can cure and prevent
disease with vitamins minerals how many
of you heard a read stuff like that from
doctors they say that all the
time evidence-based medicine we're we're
for evidence-based
medicine that's what they say now that's
the modern version of
it well how many of you know that you
can prevent and cure scurvy with vitamin
C raise your
hand we've known that since
1721 how many of you know you can
prevent and cure rickets with vitamin D
raise your
hand now doctors are the ones who made
vitamin D deficiency occur in every
human being in America it's a physician
caused disease that every one of us in
America is vitamin D3 deficient don't
you dare go out in the sun if you do you
got to have skin blocker SPF 7
billion if to wear long sleeves gloves
and a big brim hat don't go out in the
Moonlight you'll get skin cancer you
cannot eat eggs because that Yol will
get you from cholesterol then don't you
dare take any vitamins minerals you'll
overdose now they charge you $300 to do
a vitamin D3 test and then you write
your prescription for 150 bucks for
something you can get for free for just
standing out in the sun for a half
hour they think you're doing a favor
when they caused everybody in America to
be vitamin D3
deficient you all heard the seven food
group pyramid which is is kind of funny
because the doctors and the government's
not stupid so they see us getting sicker
and sicker dying younger and younger and
all these terrible things happening they
said well it must be that the seven food
group pyramids to to too complicated for
Americans I mean it's seven so they've
now squished it down to a flat four food
group plate because seven was too
complicated for you really well that's
what they say the pyramid was toppled
for a four food group plate now because
this is less complicated Seven's too big
a number for you that's what they're
saying now now doctors wants you to
believe the government wants you to
believe this would be a good meal you
got some vegetables there you got
broccoli cauliflower carrots you know
the broccoli is green you got some
magnesium in there cuz it requires
magnesium to make chlorophyll so you
know that it's got some magnesium in
there you know there's two other
minerals you don't know what they are
but you got some two other minerals you
got cauliflower you don't know what's in
there and carrots you got some beta
carotene which is kind of a pre vitamin
A then you got the um uh raspberries and
the blueberries which have some nice
antioxidants and then of course there's
cantaloupe I wouldn't eat that cuz you
get leria
D and then you have a piece of chicken
breast here which has some amino acids
but it's dangerous because it's got some
burned areas in the fat which turn into
heterocyclic means and cause cancer and
then you have too much carbohydrates
which is not an essential nutrient if
you're not cutting trees and plowing
with your plow without engine pulling it
you're just pushing the plow yourself
you don't need that much calories from
carbohydrates okay so you got a little
bit of antioxid how many orex points in
there you don't know you know you need
20,000 to live a long time like these
long lived people but how many's in
there you don't
know so how can you how can you eat like
that and guarantee that you're getting
everything you need an optimal amount
there's only one way ladies and
gentlemen you must
supplement you must supplement with the
almighty 90 you must supplement with the
almighty 90 60 minerals 16 bioms 12
essenti three essential fatty acids and
people tell me why I can't do that $2 a
day is too much and then they're
standing there with a cup of Starbucks
Coffee espresso latte mocha smoka cha
GLA
Goa for eight bucks yeah now there's two
problems with that attitude number
one if you die 50 years early or 25
years early you're cheating your
grandkids of your wisdom keep them out
of trouble and steer them in the right
direction right you're going to leave
them to some government
guy think about
that or worse yet your kids's going to
die 25 to 50 years early and you'll be
burying them because you wouldn't give
them the vitamins and
minerals do not listen to doctors when
it comes to nutrition they know
nothing I'm going to give you a couple
of diseases that are physician produced
disease physician caus diseases and then
we'll call this quits here and then
we'll bring in the the giveaways which
everybody likes how many you heard of
Alzheimer's disease Alzheimer disease is
a physician cause disease repeat that
Alzheimer disease is a physician cause
disease Alzheimer disease is a physician
cause disease Alzheimer disease is a
physician caused disease is there
anybody that did not hear me here raise
your hand okay the reason I can say that
is this Alzheimer disease did not occur
40 years ago even by another name now
it's the number four killer of adults in
the United States over the age of
65 now what is Alzheimer disease well
it's a going away of the milon the
insulation material in the brain the
white matter of the brain which makes up
75% of the brain weight when the milin
goes away and you don't have enough raw
materials to replace it these naked
nerve fibers get all tangled up you've
all heard the nerve Tangles right in the
milin they short circuit and your memory
doesn't work
that's what that's what alers is well
this m in the brain that makes up 75% of
your brain weight is 100%
cholesterol so you go on a cholesterol
restricted diet you're eating egg
beaters instead of eggs egg white
omelets you're EA margin and canola oil
instead of cream and butter and
lard and eggs and you're eating tofu
instead of red meat you're eating
boneless skinless chicken breasts now
how they grow chicken without skin I
don't know but they figured that one
out you're better off throwing away the
chicken and eating the
skin then if you can't get your blood
cholesterol below 200 normal remember is
220 270 if you can't get your blood
cholesterol below 200 they give you
cholesterol lowering
drugs then you can't remember who you
are because you have Alzheimer disease
now because you can't rebuild the mild
in the brain now how many of you heard
of erectile dysfunction Ed I mean all
you have to do is is watch TV every
night but after 10:00 at night right
here's Bob selling en
Zite
Bob and then there's seala she got two
people in two different bathtubs waiting
for the right moment oh God I mean these
people are dumber than rocks because you
have to be in the same bathtub before
there's the right moment I mean they
don't know anything about the birds and
the
bees and then there's Viagra oh if you
have the side effect of an erection for
48 hours contact
us well if that isn't an incentive give
me the side effect
man so why do we have erectile
dysfunction well there erectile
dysfunction is caused by a lack of the
production of testosterone the male
hormone no male hormone there's nobody
home anymore right I mean this is not
difficult well testosterone is a steroid
hormone is 95% by weight cholesterol
so you go on a cholesterol restricted
diet your cholesterol Ling drugs there
ain't nobody home
anymore so you want scream in the
neighborhood again you got to eat 68
eggs a day
folks you take the mighty 0 and 68 eggs
a day and they'll be Hallelujah holiday
again boy let me tell
you and then of course menopause you
ladies don't get off easy menopause is
also a physician caused disease I want
you to think about it progesterone
estrogen or two steroid
hormones all you do is eat 68 eggs a day
ladies take the mighty 90 and you won't
have any problems you won't need Prine
which is hor PE if you know this but hor
hor PE not I should I it's Mar's pee
okay it's Mar's pee it is more correct
that they make pran
from that's a wonderful fun thing you
ever wonder why you Winnie every time
now it comes from a horse p
now your grandma used to go through
menopause in 3 seconds when she was 70
years old she was having pregnancy in
her 60s right now half our our young
women's life I mean 30 years you're
suffering from menopause and go through
five husbands and and uh you know all
the symtoms and everything you're
willing to the symptoms are so terrible
you're willing to take drugs that'll
make you have cancer and everything just
to get rid of the hot flashes okay then
there is sleep apnea how many you heard
of sleep apnea that's another physician
caused disease now sleep apnea is a
normal beh behavior I'm going to repeat
that again sleep apnea is a normal
behavior anybody who's alive has sleep
apnea watch a dog sleep watch a baby
sleep they'll breathe for about 10 15
minutes and then they slowly stop
breathing and they'll quit breathing for
about 2 minutes until their carbon
dioxide level is raised above a certain
line they'll take a deep breath and
start breathing again as they're blowing
off all the carbon dioxide when the
carbon dioxide goes below a certain line
they stop breathing comes up above the
line they take a deep bre they start
breathing again it's a normal sleep
Behavior so everybody they send to The
Sleep Lab is 100% going to have sleep AA
because it's a normal behavior then they
say one of these stupid sleep one of the
Sleep Pat machines you sound like Darth
Vader oh that's
romantic that'll knock the population
down and then and then we have um let's
see what is it oh snoring snor snoring
is supposed to cause heart attacks I
mean come on snoring caus heart attack
no no no but doctors oh well we got to
do surgery we got to Ambi out lunar moth
slighting around I mean this is really
weird stuff here was snoring well how
did Grandma and Grandpa deal with it
they slept in separate bedrooms it was
free nobody died they just slept in
separate bedrooms now the only time
you're going to die from storing is when
your sleep partner hit you in the head
with a
pot now when they wanted to get frisky
grandma or Grandpa would put a blue
Thumbtack above the eyes of the kids
Grandpa and the little kid would say
grandpa why are you so happy today he
says some when you grow up you'll find
out
okay you're getting the idea so many of
these things we suffer from today are
physician caused
diseases and then we pay them to fix the
disease they cause it's like you go to a
guy to change the all and he takes your
brake pads off you say man my my brakes
are squeaking they're not very good you
go back there I got to replace your
brake
pads that's what doctors
do you see cuz they gain the system
remember the senate committee came out
just yeah months ago and said doctors
are gaming the system
now they do it every day to every one of
you so you got to stop using them except
for emergency you're unconscious even in
your sleep your prayer should be I hope
the doctor is sober when I get there but
other than emergency been R over by a
truck or fall off a roof do not go to a
doctor take care of yourself first as
grandma okay do not go to them for every
little thing just ask Andy
Rooney okay so with that I'm going to
get Vivan and Jerry and whoever's coming
up here they're going to give away a
bunch of stuff and here they come let's
give them a hand they're going to give
you away a lot of
things and then I'll come back and
answer questions for you we'll have a
lot of fun we'll save a lot of kids
that's the main goal here let's give Dr
Wallock a hand for thank you thank you
thank
you thank
you for